I'm always down. Did Stardust turn on Tom? I don't know. I actually
I haven't been following. I was like thinking about watching
this last night. I was going to watch it and then I was just
like in a call or something last night for a while. All right,
we're going to engage the Tom 10 or the Tom 10 adjacent content.
Jeez. >> Feel entitled to me defending you and you are
not entitled to me defending you. Thank you.
>> I don't want you to defend him. Okay, [__]
that [__] I it wasn't what she did or like defending
him. The reason is because the why she decided she wouldn't defend
Tom. She pronounced publicly. She said publicly that the reason
why she didn't want to defend Tom was because she's heard a lot
of rumors and she's basically believing them. And that's the
problem I have. The problem I >> we finishing off the Tomtent.
I mean, we might as well just do this, right? I feel like we
might as well. I'm just trying to see if there's a time stamp,
but Mantis is just going to spur. I think it's like pretty funny
to just listen to Mantis freak out about >> I have is that
she said publicly on her stream that he's misleading people and
he's he's like
dealing with people in females in his community and she spread
all of those
and then she said that's why I can't defend Tom. It's not fair.
You can't just spread rumors.
>> That's my problem. >> I mean you can and I did.
So >> is there a way in? Yeah, I know. I went further in.
I just wanted to hear when the Kilo guy joins cuz apparently
that's when the conversation gets way better. Okay, Stardust
comes back. Get Mantis on. I mean, yeah, it would be funny to
have Mantis on again. Did nobody watch this? I thought for sure
we'd have somebody here who watched this. Hold on. Let me see.
Uh, hold on. Kilo. Oh, wait. Is Kilo in the first part of the
conversation and I skipped by it? Maybe I'm an idiot. Hold on.
Hey, Daxi. The milkshake. I'm doing good. Well, maybe Kilo's
in the first part. He is in the first part. Oh, I'm an idiot.
>> The caveat. We'll just start from the >> Like
the count was marked. >> One second. I'm going to put my
desk >> Either way, also I just left servers. >> I'm
gonna have to touch my mic here. And I feel like I'm almost certainly
going to my [__] up. We're watching it through Queman.
He's covering everything from the beginning. Okay. Yeah. I mean,
I'm starting from the beginning, too. But you go nuts. Feel free
to support Quean. Um, I mean, my my perception, um, based on
what I've gathered is that, um, Tom was, uh, and again, I'm going
to be clear with like food shops, I don't think that abuse is
always known or intentional. I don't think it's I think abuse
is caveat. The caveats are boring. Just just explain your point.
>> Sure. I think that I think that Tom was uh, sort of
abusive to Sassifras. >> Okay. Why?
Why was he abusive or what? >> Well, the abusive part would
be like exploiting her friendship, that close friendship, possibly
her romantic intentions towards him for free labor and then lying
about his relationship with you because he knew that a romantic
relationship with you would upset her and possibly send her away
and up his
>> Why do I think that?
>> I Hang on. Hang on. Food shops. This is I I would >> Yeah.
Yeah. Go ahead. Go ahead. I don't want to silence stardust and
food shops, but I just I feel like I know. >> Okay, I'll
be quiet. Yeah. Okay. Yeah, go ahead. Yeah. >> Yeah. Uh,
Kilo, why do you think Tom was abusive to Sassifrass? >> Go
to 1.25. >> Um, so I think he was abusive to Sassifrass
in being withholding with what it was that the nature of your
relationship was. And I think that um it benefited him to have
SAS around for a variety of reasons. And I think that he played
to whatever position it would put him in to be able to keep SAS
around for longer. Wow, he stole it. >> Uh, is there a
reason why you think that? Is that based on DMs that that you've
seen? And have you talked to SAS and have you talked to Tom?
>> Yeah, I've talked to both of them. >> Is that
based? >> Okay, so you think that >> Let me let me
Can we back up for a >> Uh, is that based on you talking
to them, you stupid? Uh, yeah, it is actually. It is. Oh. Oh,
okay. All >> Uh, I don't know. I just want to actually
I just want to riff off what you like. You stated your argument.
I just want to riff off that before you back up because backing
up is weird. Um >> I just wanted to give you a bigger picture
but you can go ahead. >> Oh, you got a bigger picture.
Okay, go ahead. Go for it. >> Um that I don't think that
Tom is intentionally voluntarily malicious or intent. When you
say when you like say in a sentence your argument about Tom being
abusive towards SAS, do you think it's okay to just walk around
saying I think Tom is abusive to SAS and then as like a post
hawk thing you say I don't think it was intentional. How do you
think that comes? >> It's not really that's not really
a post thing. I think most abuse is unintentional. I think I
think most abuses is like they don't know that they're doing
it. >> Okay. Well, I didn't know what you thought. I'm
sorry. I didn't read your >> No, that's okay. >> Carry
on. >> Yeah. So I think most like I would I would estimate
>> Hey, he didn't read his mind cuz when he was about to
start explaining to you, you cut him off. >> I don't have
any like data to support this, but like I think that like most
abuse like >> Stop stop. You don't have any data to support
this. >> I don't have hard numbers. This is just based
on what I understand about the nature of abuse. >> So am
I am I gathering that this is just >> This is what I've
understood about the nature of psychological or emotional
>> So how tell me how do you know about Tom and Sass's
relationship intimately? Do you know all of the details? all
of the context or are you just gathering information and >> this
is the gayest way of arguing. I absolutely despise this >> and
riffing off that. >> You have a study on Tom and Sass's
relationship cuz uh I I don't think you actually have omnisient
knowledge of their relationship and therefore you can't judge
it. >> I'm gathering information but both based on what's
been available publicly and through speaking to both of them.
>> Okay. So I know how you talk privately and I know how
you like the information you gathered publicly. Sure. >> So
I know you don't have all the context. I'm I'm not saying I have
100% of the context. No. >> So then I feel like it's weird
for you to get up on panels and assert something that you don't
have 100% context for. >> Well, why don't you give us your
thoughts on on what >> Yeah, just all of Twitch poll shouldn't
actually exist. None of you guys have context on like everything.
You don't have data on everything you say. Absolutely nothing
should exist here. Are you gay spiritually too to use a gay as
an insult? No, I just use gay as an >> The situation is
mantis. That is not my place to give the context of Tom and Sass's
relationship. I feel divided by Tom and Sass. And I feel like
it's weird that people are providing context and assumptions
and narratives based on a relationship that they do not have
the full context for. I know stuff, but I it's not my place to
release it. And because I know stuff, I am very willing to get
up here and call people out on their lack of context.
>> And I think that's very important. So, I think Kilo,
I think it's very strange that you get up here and you say, "I
>> no, it's not gay to use gay as an insult. Shut up."
>> Context. You don't have context.
>> You declare publicly on a live stream that you think
Tom is abusive towards SAS. I think it's very strange because
I think you have morals and ethics and you're very virtuous.
I've noticed you're around. You have a you're very uh this is
your thing. Uh, but I think it's weird that you've come to these
conclusions yet you I don't think you've actually
maybe the reason your private talks with Tom didn't include the
context because Tom isn't as nasty as us and he's not willing
to leak DMs. Have you thought about that? >> I mean Tom
has offered to provide
more logs and more context if I needed and I decided that I didn't
really need it. So it's not like he's unwilling to do so. >> Oh,
but you you decided you didn't need it. Why? had you come up
with a narrative and you just wanted it to be the narrative.
>> So if anytime I've decided that I think I have a clear
understanding of what's >> it means that I'm necessarily
ignoring whatever context you think I I shouldn't be ignoring.
>> That's very strange that you decided you had a clear
narrative without the context. I think that's very strange. >> Okay.
So what >> the information that would have provided >> listen
why why is everybody so up in arms when like I people can just
make predictions. They can go here's the data I've observed literally
like you shouldn't be asking what he knows. You should just say
like, "Why do you think this?" And then let him explain why he
thinks it. You don't have to say like, you don't you don't have
to make the assertion, "Oh, you don't have enough data to say
something." You haven't even heard out why he thinks what he
does. Shut the up and listen for two seconds, you stupid Kiwi.
Whoops. Sorry, I meant [__] I don't know. Not was
appropriate. That feels really awkward for me. Okay. >> Provided
you just like a nice Canadian up on public stream. >> How
can I deny information that I know would provide me context if
I don't know what the information is? No, you just said to me
that you decided you had enough context so you didn't need the
information Tom said he would supply to >> Yeah. So, like
in the specific instances that I'm very slimy. >> I'm not
being slimy. Can you can >> very slimy. >> Take two
steps back. Take a deep breath. We'll take two steps back. Okay.
>> No, I'm literally reading it as you're presenting it
and it's very >> I feel like you're misunderstanding what
I'm saying. So there's a difference between uh me wanting to
accept a specific narrative and running with that and fusing
any attempts to clarify otherwise and um someone saying well
I can provide you more logs of this if you need and me thinking
well if you provide me logs of that it actually wouldn't really
change like my perspective like you providing another message
or >> What you're saying is what you're saying is he did
provide enough logs and you like read all the logs.
>> You made the claim that he wouldn't leak DMs and I'm
telling you that he told me he would provide me more DMs that
have been made publicly available. So that's the thing that I'm
pushing back against. Okay. Now, >> so what you're telling
me is you just don't have 100% context. >> No one has 100%
context. You don't even have 100% context.
>> I'm I want to punch this person. >> I just I find
it weird that you're getting up. >> Get me the last
You just talked to You just talked to food shops for however
long and you don't have 100% context. So, who is qualified to
speak on this? >> Wait, how is me talking to food shops
going to get context? I have a lot more context than food shops.
Food shops doesn't give me any suggest. So, I just wish they'd
stop using the word context in general. Like, just say knowledge,
right? I know stuff. I have facts. Like,
>> needs more context. I'm saying who's qualified to talk
about this because it sounds like you're saying I shouldn't be
talking about this. Who's qualified?
>> Uh, who are you? Are you qualified to talk about this?
I don't think you are. >> It seems like you're the one
who's requiring a certain amount of qualification. So, I'm asking
you, what is the standard for being qualified to talk about?
>> I don't think you I don't think you are. >> Okay.
Why? >> Great. But what's the question? The question is,
the question is who is who who is qualified to talk about this
>> SAS, SAS and Tom. >> Okay. So, no one else can
offer their opinion or their take on it or whatever because they're
all necessarily missing
>> Yes. All I'm all I'm pointing out is that everyone else
who's talking about it doesn't have 100% context. So, all of
their like uh scenarios and narratives and the things. >> Tom
and Sass don't even have 100% context, right? They don't even
have 100% context. There's a bunch of about like what Tom was
saying to Mantis, what their relationship status was, right,
that SAS would have been not privy to. There's a bunch of stuff
about stat SAS's state of mind that Tom wouldn't have been privy
to. Nobody's 100. Nobody's omnisient. You don't need omniscience
to judge people. As I'm about to >> not Dan donated $5.
I was going to donate for Tomant. Instead, Ilsav is a genius
with great takes on JSDLK's lack of morals. Yeah, true. Listen,
we're not talking about we're not talking about Tom. We're not
reacting to Tom. I'm reacting to Mantis, who I actually dislike
and I don't have any conunction about
uh making fun of or reacting to.
>> Their opinions are just that. And I think unfortunately
what's happening in the space is that everyone has these ideas,
these narratives. They're in these communities and some people
are bad faith. I don't think you're bad faith, but I do think
you have an opinion and you're getting up and you're uh you're
very vehemently expressing that and pushing back on people who
deny that. And I think it's weird to be so certain of your opinion
when it is just that, an opinion. And I I want the audience to
realize that Kilo just has an opinion.
>> Okay. So, you have an issue with how matterof factly
I'm stating my opinion. >> Yeah. And I think it's Yeah.
I think you have declared uh over the course of a couple a couple
of days >> this kilo guy uh I think he was mad at me for
calling Thomas Xb best and then he at some point he like was
in general chat and he was just like I was wrong about everything
but listen I think it's based when you just come out and say
like hey I don't yeah I could be wrong here's like here's what
I'm thinking here's why I'm saying what I'm saying those are
fun conversations when you don't have all the information you're
inferring from like a bunch of skitso signals you have I don't
even think he's doing that I think he's operating off of pretty
solid information. But it's like it's fun to just give an opinion.
That's all he was ever doing was giving an >> I'm unsubing.
Uh I'm like I have made I'm making this declaration. I'm taking
this stance. Yeah, I think it's >> a lot of them are memes,
by the way. Like I posted a copy pasta about smashing my TV in
front of my children. I don't have children. Um so some of that
is jokes by the way. >> I don't think it's a meme in the
middle of Tom's like very serious like stream where he's very
stressed to say I'm unsubing. Tom I'm sympathetic to him being
stressed. I'm I'm sympathetic to him being stressed out. Yes.
But the >> declaration publicly. >> What was the
declaration that I made? >> I'll get a screenshot. But
you said I'm unsubing. I can't believe this. I cannot >> So
the thing that you're referencing the thing that you're referencing
is uh me saying I won't be a subscriber next year. I just smashed
my TV in front of my children. I just My wife took the kids to
a hotel.
Copy pasta. Yeah. Yeah.
Hang on. That's not funny. In the middle of a very serious stream.
>> You may not think it's funny, but I didn't make a decision
based. >> Okay. I'm going to take a screenshot. I didn't
think you said I'm smashing my TV. I genuinely didn't see any
of the
>> If I'm wrong, >> if I'm wrong, I'll eat it. That's
fine. >> What do What do you think is the most I What do
you think the ideal thing for people in this like sphere who
know this conversation is happening about these two? What do
you What would be the ideal thing that you would want from a
content creator in the sphere who is kind of compelled to cover
something like this? >> Is that Stardust?
Did she just ask a good question that they somebody replaced
her? I've never seen this before. She just asks asked like a
relevant, pertinent, actually insightful question that I actually
want to know about. There's no way >> who you ask who would
know this. >> She just said, "Hey, uh, you're having an
inappropriate rea or you're having an reaction to how this guy's
describing it. How would you want other content c creators to
describe it?" >> Think is the most I what do you think
the ideal thing for people in this like sphere who know this
conversation is happening about these two? What do you what would
be the ideal thing that you would want from a content creator
in the sphere who is kind of compelled to cover something like
this? >> Insane asking that too. >> Um I would just
hope that they didn't hear look I know there's been like apparently
evidence supplied, right? >> I just hope they wouldn't
accept the evidence so readily from people that are clearly bad
actors. It's >> easy. Are you saying you never want to
hear the word context again? Maybe you don't have enough context
to be judging why we're saying context.
I wish they or they had no credentials. I wish that they wouldn't
hang on. >> That's fine. Go. >> I wish that they
wouldn't uh pick up on everything that's been supplied. So, >> everything
literally coming out of bad faith places. And I wish that they
wouldn't just buy that and then when Tom says anything because
they're so invested in that narrative, just that's it. It doesn't
matter anything he says. You are allowed to have criticis criticisms
of Tom and how he portrays things. But I feel like a lot of the
narratives that are spreading around, I I I could ask you every
single narrative and argument you have about the situation and
I could ask you for evidence and you would never provide me with
the full context. And I know that and I know that because no
one >> You have no evidence. You have no
>> Only people that have supplied evidence have been South
Africa and bad faith people. Tom hasn't even leaked DMs. >> Okay.
I feel like everyone
in the space has picked up on the story and said, "Oh yeah, this
looks like this and therefore it must be this and therefore oh
my god this is so bad." >> Okay, so you know the only reason
that SAS ever leaked DMs is because she was directly responding
to Tom what she perceived to be lies about her, right? >> Oh,
like what the PR statement? >> Yeah, for instance, >> hang
on. What in that statement was wrong? They were friends. Well,
they already Okay, they already went over this, but I'm just
saying the only reason she proceeded >> answer me. >> Wait,
you already know this. I don't have to answer for S. She already
like laid out her case. I'm just saying >> I want to let
everybody What was wrong in that statement that they were >> I'm
not here to literally walk you through all of Sass's arguments.
You seem like you already know them. I'm just telling you the
only reason she leaked the M. >> You brought up Sass's
arguments and you said that she laid them out and that's why
there's a problem. >> I'm bringing them up to tell you
that the only reason that she leaked the MS in the first place
is because she believed him to be publicly lying about her. Okay.
So if that's the case,
>> yes, in the PR statement,
she thought he was uh he was lying about her and was basically
misrepresenting exactly why she was leaving. >> For instance,
yeah, I don't remember this. It's been 6 days of 19. >> Just
because it's a PR statement doesn't mean you can just lie about
this. >> This is very important. No, hang on, Kilo. This
is very important. You said the reason why Seth did all of the
leaking of DMs over the last few days that she has done is because
of one statement that Tom put out. >> Yes.
I'm sure there might have been more to it, but sure. Yeah. >> No,
you said it was because of something he did. And this only thing
he's ever leaked about SAS is the PR statement. So, please clarify
in that PR statement what you're so adamantly defending against
Tom. Like >> they were not friends and that that they were
not friends. Hold on. But can I answer the question, Mantis,
for the love of God? Like, if you want me to answer the question,
I'll [__] answer the question. Okay. Said they weren't
friends, that she had made it exceedingly clear that she was
done with him. How's this going to remain reason were the the
reason why she had left. What if I told you? What if I told you
that the end of that conversation was them saying, "You can reach
out to me. We can still be in touch. Let's see. Let's reassess
things and and and it left on those terms, >> which is
what Tom said, right?" >> That's his experience of this.
Okay. >> Does that matter at all to you? >> Where's
the Kelly? >> If someone says I'm 100% done, >> I
don't know if Kelly wants me to have the loop on stream, but
I can put it on. Hold on. I don't think she minds it. I actually
have like a better loop now, too. I think I'll hit play on this.
I'll >> with you. And then the other person says, "Well,
you can always reach out to me if you change your mind or whatever."
Do you think that it's fair for that person to be like, "We're
still friends and we're all good." Like, that's clearly not the
exchange that they had. >> No, I don't think I don't think
Okay. I think it's very weird that for someone to put out a statement
saying that everything's fine. Like, do you think it would be
better for Tom to put out a statement saying SAS is awesome,
blah blah blah, but we're not friends anymore. We definitely
aren't going to be in contact. She's not allowed around this
space. Uh, we are not on good terms. Like, I I don't understand
what people are actually getting upset about. A lot of the things
you get upset about Kilo, like if you're really going to nitpick
about the PR statement and the fact that he said, "We're friends.
It's cool. Everything's fine." To smooth things over in a situation
that was highly tense, I think it's >> Kelly's Kelly's
just enjoying the Tom 10. Okay. Kelly loves it. >> Very
weird. >> I don't say about, I say about about. >> You're
going to come at someone and say he's lying. Obviously, there's
a reason. >> I do think he was lying. Okay. So, and I'm
sympathetic to like there maybe being reasons why someone might
lie. >> No, you're not sympathetic. You're actually using
it as a as a thing to say that Tom is manipulative and disgusting.
That's what you're doing. >> So, I think what he's gonna
say is he would look at who the lies serve, right? So, that's
probably what's leading to him thinking that Tom's abusive in
this situation or unintentionally abusive is that when he lies,
who are the lies who are the lies serving? Does lying about their
friendship serve Tom or Sas?
I think it's pretty obvious. Uh that's that's what's informing
his decision here and like how he's forming his >> You're
doing >> Yeah. Yeah. It's >> big. Big big I don't
say big. >> Say bagg. Okay. >> If I think him being
self- serving in his life. >> Okay. Please give me two
three four
in his I just genuinely can 100% immediately guarantee that you
do not have the full context. >> Okay. So for instance
spreading this around because you're close to SAS and that's
what you do. You're close to people and you spread around narratives
because you happen to be close to them. Anyway, yeah. Okay. So,
I think like for instance, he lied about the the nude immediately
and it was mainly to protect
>> Uh, do you think it was mainly to protect himself or
do you think maybe I >> I disagree with that. I think that
could be equally I don't think that's actually to protect Tom.
I think that could be to protect Mantis entirely. I don't I don't
Yeah, that's not a good one. That's not a good first one. Couldn't
the lies serve both in this situation? The lives The lies could
serve both. I don't think they do. >> Want people to know
that it was my nude. >> No, no, no. That would be an acceptable
No, no, no. That would be an acceptable defense. Like I think
I even said before I do think that's a part of it. Do you think
maybe I didn't want our relationship public? Do you think maybe
our private life private? >> I don't think that Tom has
demonstrated a tendency to really care about what other people
want or feel. >> Okay, so here's what I'm saying about
this thing. What happens with people like Kilo is they come into
these conversations, they have a narrative, and then when I say
maybe the reason he did this is because I wanted a private, he
wanted a private, he has a narrative already in his head that
says I don't think Tom has a tendency to care. Therefore, that
is clearly disable. He's demonstrated that I think he's literally
demonstrated that he has an unwillingness to care about what
other people feel. >> Do you disagree with this? >> Because
is this because you have a relationship with SAS? >> No.
My relationship with SAS is completely irrelevant to this >> It
doesn't sound like it. >> Okay. I think your relationship
to Tom is not devoid of your perception of this particular situation.
So, is is that
>> Not devoid to your perception of this particular situation.
Just say you you might be biased, too. As Kelly would say, less
word
uh why say more word when less word do trick. I think that's
what Kevin says, right? And Kelly. Yeah, >> nothing that
I say matters, but >> I also think you're you're probably
unwilling to accept that there might have been selfish motivations
for him lying about the nude. You think that was entirely in
preservation of you, but I >> but why do you think it's
entirely selfish? I am in this relationship too and he cares
about me too. Because I'm using context, which you seem >> Kevin.
It's Kevin from the office who says that >> be really obsessed
with to determine that Tom has >> put it into context that
we're in a relationship and he cares about me too and I didn't
want my nudes out in public. What is wrong with you, Kilo? >> I
think it would be inconvenient for you to accept that maybe he
did it out of selfish reasons to not want Z to know about the
nature of relationship. >> I think and you genuinely have
to have a hate at this point. >> No, I No, Mantis, believe
me, I'm I'm going to say this. Believe me, it would be a lot
more emotionally convenient for me if I didn't think these things
about Tom. I promise you. I promise you.
>> Um
maybe
sorry. Sorry guys. Um do you guys do you do you think that maybe
um Hilo you know that you are making so again I will just preface
this and say I don't know anything about Sass's side of the story
here right but do you think that maybe um just just you know
in with the nudes issue itself um >> do you think that
maybe you are kind of coming to a conclusion when you are not
like the in but you're not in the relationship with Tom? I kind
of see what he's saying that like so the nude thing I thought
was to protect Mantis, but I think he's I don't know if he's
said it because I haven't heard him say it directly, but I think
the nude thing he's going to argue is like the reason Tom lied
was because he didn't want Sasra to know, which actually given
everything we've seen in DMs actually makes sense, right? That
he would lie about it so that Sass wouldn't know. So he wouldn't
reveal his relationship to Sasra. like Mantis and and Tom, you
know, that's kind of >> still also to defend Mantis somewhat,
>> I don't know how much more I should say, but I think
I >> I find it I find it very gross that Kilo is jumping
to a lot of conclusions based on his inside information only
from SAS. He's I I know about the conversation he had with Tom
and I know exactly what he asked and I know all the loaded questions
and I know exactly what he already assumed. >> Did Tom
Wait, wait, did Tom go to you and say that I asked questions?
>> I know I know all of these. I know everything that has
happened and I know that Kilo is walking around. >> I think
that's insane. If Tom went to you and said that I had loaded
questions, then you guys are both >> He didn't he didn't
say that to me. Walking around and Kilo has a narrative and he
>> Wait, what? Isn't Sass dating the Mantis the guy Mantis
is speaking with? He's admitted as much just in this combo.
I don't think so. That would change a lot about what I'm saying
or what about what I think. I haven't seen that come out in this
conversation. >> And he has to push it. And I think >> Tom,
wait. Tom is the only person I told about that conversation.
So what did he say to one time? One time. One time. >> How?
Okay. So why are you saying that I asked Tom loaded questions?
Where does that come from? >> He didn't. I just know you
you asked me loaded questions in DMs a number of times and I
think it's very This is how you operate.
>> Okay. Um I think when I ask you,
>> would you like me to pull up our DMs? Because I have
all of them and I can easily pull them up and I show that the
way you ask questions is very loaded. You want to know exactly
what you think about the situation. You have an idea in your
head. This is how you >> Mantis asked about his relationship
with SAS. I don't I I literally missed that. Yeah, sorry. He
didn't deny. Okay. Yeah, I'm I think you're misunderstanding
It I think it's a platonic relationship as in they're close.
They're friends. I don't think Mantis, from what I've heard,
I don't think Mantis is even close to intimating that they are
uh like eating or anything like that. Yeah, I I Yeah, I doubt
it. I very much doubt it. preface everything when you talk to
people and then you walk around because you have an you're very
convict you have big conviction Kilo and I love how you walk
around but I don't like how you're spinning a narrative and I
think you do not have the full context and I I don't like how
you think you know you do I think it's wrong that you're walking
>> I think this kilo guy seems kind of like me I like having
arguments where I'm like trying to mind readad somebody and making
the argument with everyone um based on like just what I perceive
cuz I might be wrong but I just like talking through like my
thought process process with other people and having like counter
examples brought up. It's just like a fun it's fun to figure
out like where the holes are in your perception. I think this
is like a very enjoyable conversation for me personally.
It sounds like he might be the same kind of person. Uh would
you ever eate a fan just asking for a friend? No. >> Saying
you know you do. >> No e- dating. E dating is gay. Okay.
>> And that you're saying Sass is the victim here and Tom
is the perpetrator. I think Let me say this. >> Absolutely.
I have a question. I have a >> Wait wait wait. Can I respond
to me very very briefly and then you can ask me a question. I
just want to say mantis, it's not that I think that I um have
all of the answers and I 100% have all the context in my mind
made up. If >> Good. I'm glad you said that. >> Okay.
If I were ever present, >> say it more proudly, say it
more often. >> Hey, stop. We need to make progress.
Generally, generally speaking, when people express their opinion,
especially about a really complicated interpersonal matter like
this, people are going to say, "This is what I think." They're
not going to endlessly caveat by saying, "I may not have all
the information, and like I'm not really super blah blah." This
is just my perception of it. I could be wrong. I don't know.
But this is generally kind of >> I do I do have a question.
I do have a question before you guys get back into it. Okay,
Hilo, you have said that you like you've said like multiple times
down this conversation there that there are other details that
um that make you think that Tom is being manipulative or Tom
was um abusive to SAS.
Are is is are is there information that you have that all of
us don't know about? >> I so I it's a little bit hard to
keep track of like what it is that Zonia leaked and what it is
that like Tom showed which I don't think Tom really showed anything
that is >> hold on. Jesus Christ. >> Just just let
him answer. It's hard. It's hard for me to keep track of it.
So me saying, "Hey, Kilo, do you have information we don't have?"
That's, by the way, like 10, eight words or something that just
gets straight to the >> Um, I'm not sure how much I should
say is because I might have seen things that I'm not 100% sure
are public already. So, I'd rather just not even really understand
it. Um, I am deriving some of my opinions based on those things,
but I don't feel confident enough to be able to be like, "Yeah,
this is what one thing that I've seen said. I'm not I'm not willing
to to go that far. It's not that important to me." >> Hang
on. I I take issue with the fact that he cannot provide actual
certain evidence, yet he's willing to come up here and call Tom
abusive. I take issue with that. So if if I if I've produced
inadequate evidence to you, that's fine. My problem is that I
think that the the threshold of evidence for people to be able
to say that someone is a manipulative abuser seems like it's
it's I don't know. It seems like it's not something that um it's
not tangible. There's no amount of things that I can present
for someone. >> Tangible and it's very important when you're
accusing someone of being a manipulative abuser. You have to
provide >> It's not tangible at all to Mantis. She's just
going to always say you don't have enough context. And she proved
that when she refused to answer the question like, "Hey, how
should people be acting?" And she was basically like, "Nobody
should talk unless they know everything." Are you kidding me?
That's a completely impossible bar to get to full evidence or
what you're doing is actual slander in my opinion. And it's wrong
of you to do that. And I don't understand why everyone sits around
thinking it's okay for someone like Kilo to come up and say some
words like that and put them on someone like that and say that's
okay with no certain evidence. That is [__] wrong.
I will stand here till my dying day, I will die on this [__]
hill and say that is wrong. If you want to carry on this narrative
because Kilo said, I think based on XY Z that I can't provide
and I think this and I don't think that and >> Wait, hold
on. No one hold on. No one's carrying up my narrative, right?
Like I think before you came on, Food Shop was pressing me on
some of the things I was saying. This is just my opinion. So,
>> yes. And you haven't given you all you've done is said
Tom is definitely a manipulative abuser, but I do not have actual
evidence. >> I think that Tom is a manipulative abuser.
Okay. But um you know >> you think that kilo I'm here in
this call to say to everyone don't take this opinion that seriously
because he has not provided adequate evidence. >> Yeah.
People don't have to take my opinion that seriously. I don't
I don't ask it or require it of anybody. >> Then stop proclaiming
it like you know what the you're talking about. >> So it
sounds like you just have a problem with my tone. And if that's
the case, we've been talking for a long time based on this tone
alone. Okay. >> I do. >> I'm sorry that my tone upset
you. >> I have a problem with your insertion in this argument
when you don't have evidence. if you're gonna insert yourself
in an argument. >> She sounds a bit like Supreme, I'm guessing.
So, I don't know who this is in his like avatar or whatever.
>> but I missed getting it there.
>> I I just get the feeling that he's like a philosophy,
bro. >> I'm sorry that meant to upset you, >> And
your lack of evidence. Thank you. >> To be fair, Mantis's
entire point is that you were hopping onto streams and stuff
and asserting that, right? It's not just like giving your opinion.
You are making like >> hopping on to streams. I've literally
talked to you before really question Mantis on anything she was
saying, but >> Okay, you can question her now with no >> You
just question. >> Okay. I have a I have a question. Um
so um I guess so Mantis as I said I was saying to Kilo earlier
last thing that I kind of know about is that
um he jumped onto the wick panel which I think was not a great
idea. Um he then um after that hang on I just want to stop you.
Why don't you think it was a good idea?
>> Well that's that's not what we're here to talk about.
Right. Um regardless you said it wasn't a good idea. I want to
know why. I because I think you can't win an argument like that.
>> I think that it's just I think it's just an optimal.
>> Okay. So, you're just playing optics. Okay. Carry on.
>> I just fine. >> Um so, Akilo, I'm sorry. Can you
remind me like what we had gone over um about >> sometimes
I get the impression that people in this space like know the
keywords and like kind of play around with them. Like Mantis
just seems like a complete bot to me. like she sort of knows
the keywords, optics, bad faith, evidence, context, and she like
sort of spools them out in in threads that don't connect to anything.
They just this is a bunch of spaghetti. Just spaghetti
>> I just Yeah, I don't know. I don't know what you're
missing. I just I generally kind of feel like Tom was misleading
about the nature of his and Sas relationship. And then I think
that translating misleading about >> and I'll be clear
like I don't get that from that Kilo guy at all. that kilo guy
has a complete handle on the conversation and Mantis has no handle
on the conversation. It's just like night and day listening to
both of >> his relationship with Mantis. I think we have
other situations that that are public knowledge of instances
where Tom has been like >> upsetty spaghetti Eddie. True.
>> Um has provided dishonest framings or dishonest uh seemingly
like wild explanations for >> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. That's
fine. I what I'm what I'm asking is um Okay. So I know that um
I know that that happened. Then I know that um Tom accidentally
leaked the picture um and then the picture ended up being um
Mantis's um and then uh and then Sassifras left the Discord server
around that time and so did like a bunch of other people. So
that's where like the last part I left off on. Right. I know
that Zia did a >> Wait, can I pull something out here publicly?
Um if that's all the information you had, why did you say today
that you think Tom is a [__] boy and he misled SAS
and he misled SAS to be with me because he's a [__]
boy? Okay. So, I don't think I said specifically that he misled
Sass to be with you. Um, I said, >> I'm pretty sure that
I said >> I would want evidence of any claim Mantis is
making of like a quote because she seems to completely make things
up. Okay, she just makes up whatever she wants. Uh, hold on a
second here. Is Mantis even a content creator? I don't think
so. Not yet, at least. I know we aren't doing the Destiny asking
an example Kelly's abuse. You look bad not having anything he
can reference while yapping. What? Perpetually canled. I don't
know what you're talking about. No, you can ask for examples.
I'm saying if if somebody's quoting you uh with with Mantis specifically,
if she was quoting me, I would say I I need the quote because
you've lied about quotes several times. Okay. that that I you
know I'd heard basically I had heard through the grapevine that
um that Sassifrass I guess had feelings for Tom or something
like that and Tom had been misleading her or something like that
and that Tom was with you and Sasrass was not aware of that.
Um so
um and I >> you didn't have evidence for >> Yeah.
No, I I don't. No, I and I said as much on stream, right? Later
on, you had messaged me. You said, "Oh, you didn't like um you
know, you were upset with me." And I said, "Okay, well, fine.
That's fair. I don't >> uh like right now." Hold on. I
don't need to see Dan Shay's first comment. Nah, Mantis looks
super aggressive and righteous, so she's displaying a lot of
tonal signs of winning this conversation. Like right now, Mantis
is always attacking or asking questions or attacking, and Kilo
and Stardust are always answering or defending, which makes her
look like she's controlling the combo and therefore winning.
I agree, Dan Shay. Like I I know you're not saying this, but
I think for dumb people, it probably looks like Mantis is doing
okay. But only if you're like sub 90 IQ. You can like follow
the conversation. You realize she's like lost. She's just attacking
cuz she has no actual argument. But I know I know you're not
saying that. I'm not making fun of you, Dan. Okay. Uh but I'm
I am making fun of somebody in my DMs who is saying Mantis is
winning cuz they are >> I don't know everything about this.
So, I did say on stream that >> I just want to point out
that it's a shame that I had to like message you and tell you
that you did that without evidence. This is my point about the
whole thing is that people are doing this thing where they just
say stuff and they think it has no consequence. And yet all of
their arguments towards Tom is, "Oh my god, all of your actions
have consequences. Why aren't you doing this thing?" Yet you're
all doing this thing with no evidence. >> I don't think
that anyone thinks that this doesn't have consequences. >> Yeah.
No, I I agree with you. I agree with you. And I said as much
on that I shouldn't have said it, right? >> Wait, is Wolf
Gand in general chat or something saying he wasn't in my DMs?
That wasn't who I was talking about. But if Wolf Gang's arguing
that Mantis is winning, I'm afraid he's also a silly boy. Okay.
>> Okay. Um, but my question on this, and again, I will
remind you like I had no problem with Tom looking up Kelly Jean's
Instagram. Like I don't think that's a big deal, right? Um, I
don't think Tom's a um just for looking up her Instagram. Um,
the other stuff that seems to have come out in the time that
I was in Ohio, and again, I was in Ohio. I was disconnected from
all this drama. Um, the stuff that came out while I was in Ohio
seems to be some like interpersonal drama with Tom and Sass and
a whole bunch of people leaving Tom's server. So, my question,
my reason I'm bringing this all up was to ask you, Mantis, what
do you think happened? I guess >> I know everything that
happened, but it's not my place to say. I know what happened
to the tea and that's why I'm frustrated. The narratives aren't,
Mantis, and I am frustrated. I know Mantis doesn't know what
happened exactly to the tea cuz her information is from Tom only
and she's openly arguing that because Kylo's Kilo's information
is from from SAS only that he's wrong.
She doesn't even understand that the exact argument she's trying
to make applies to her >> because I know everything, but
it's not my place to say. >> That's fine. That's that's
totally fine. I get that. I get that. But you do have to understand
that it is like a it is a uniquely hard position to be in that
you are a somebody who is like hearing all of this from multiple
different people and you're not hearing um anything from the
other side about like this not being the case. >> I am
I am hearing it. I'm hearing what do you mean this is so wrong.
>> I'm saying from my perspective I'm saying from my perspective
I have spent four days listening and watching and hearing all
of the narratives from every community from every person come
out. I've I've watched people run around saying stuff with certainty
that they do not have certainty on. And the reason I know they
do not have certainty on it is because I know stuff from the
side that has not been expressed. The reason the side that has
noted is is because one person in this entire situation is not
willing to like like forego their values and and spread leak
DMs with information that is going to make someone look bad.
And the reason why they don't want to do that is because that
someone has already won over the audience. They It doesn't matter
what DMs are leaked. >> Who's Who's won over the audience?
>> Okay. I don't know anything about Sassifrass. Um I don't
know anything about SAS. >> So um Okay. Well, what I'm
saying here, >> Sass didn't have to win over the audience.
Um Tom's lies were so obvious from the beginning. His lies were
so obvious that people didn't hear Sassifrass's side of the story
and they were calling him a liar. Like his lies were so brazen
and so obvious that nobody believed him before Sassifrass said
anything. I understand. I
>> My question is is how am I like what what should I do
in this case where I'm hearing all of this information and um
and uh and I'm not I'm not completely sure what's real and what's
not, but there is one side that is not saying anything about
it. >> What I would suggest people do is is like you can
report on what's happened, but you could immediately say none
of it is substantiated. We don't have the full context. We've
only heard from this side. Um, this is what's going on right
now. It seems this way, but we do not have the full context.
Tom hasn't. >> That's fine. But okay. Okay. You have to
remember individual. That's fine. But we are individual. >> Hold
on. Why aren't we calling it Tom text? You don't have the full
tom text. You don't have the full tom text. Kilo >> streamers.
We're not We're not news organizations that have
messaging us saying, "Hey, like um messaging us saying like,
hey, okay, here's what it is." You know, a lot of us are just
gathering this information by Why did you ask me that question
if you didn't want to hear the answer? >> No, I I hear
the answer. I just I'm I'm I'm trying to explain to you that
it is not um it's not that straightforward. >> Well, I
feel like if you're going to report on something, some drama
that's happening in the community, as someone who's on stream
live, I feel like I'm sorry. I'm going to put these expectations
on you. Yes. I feel like >> you can have the expectations.
That's fine. But the expectations are going to be failed again
and again and again and again. And it's and and and I you know,
I'm I the that's fine. the >> So what you're saying is
again let me let me finish let me finish let me finish let me
finish
let me finish so you can um you can say that right but again
you had a problem with me um uh needing somebody to message me
say hey Sardus that is not the entire context that is not everything
that's that is in this situation and um and uh you should know
that you had a problem that you had to message me that when in
reality mantis I don't have a team behind me >> I didn't
say I didn't I didn't say hang on stop you're already twisting
what I said I didn't say you should know this. I just say >> this
might be the most competent I've ever seen. Stardust. I know.
And it makes me feel weird. Okay. >> It's disappointing
that you would report on a story. I misunderstand. I paraphrase.
I paraphrase. Right. But you Yes. You said you disappointed.
Blah blah blah. No, I paraphrase, dude. Is that Is that really
what you >> I did not say. You're not paraphrasing because
I never said I never said that you should have done XY Z. I don't
say >> I will read it out loud. Fine. um disappointed that
you called Tom a publicly today based on no evidence and assumed
that Tom misled Sass while Mantis narrative is correct. Don't
expect you to get involved but damn. And look, Mantis, that's
fine if you're disappointed. That's all I did. I never
let
me finish. I feel I've tried incredibly balanced. I've tried
to be incredibly balanced in this. You can be disappointed in
me, but again, I do not have a team, a news team behind me. Hey,
Stardust, this is all of the information, but we haven't received
any information from Tom yet. what I have is the information
that I have heard from other people and if the other side has
not put out their narrative or has not said anything. Yeah, it's
a little bit hard for me to grab that because I'm covering something
else in the meantime.
Okay, I understand. And what I'm saying is it's weird that people
would see one narrative and know that they don't have the other
and then say, >> "No, it's not that we don't have the other.
It's that Tom has spoken and every time he's spoken, he's lied.
None of us really care anymore about what Tom has to say because
he's lied so much through all of this. Okay. And then beyond
that, also Tom's gone live and not even answered questions, not
even answered basic questions on this. So, what expectation do
we have that he's even going to provide evidence or a narrative?
It seems like he's just trying to move on. >> Say, comment.
>> Do I know that I don't have the other? Did I know that
I didn't have the other? Hang on. What information did you know
about the Tom thing? All I knew was what was what was floating
around which was that this allegedly that you know Sassifrass
and Tom uh Tom was misleading Sassifrass or something like that
right that is what I have I don't have a counternarrative from
Tom's side secondly for you to have a problem with me calling
him a boy like I've called him a we know he's a that's fine okay
I'm sorry I offended you with that boy is not in >> sorry
I I might have to back up and listen to Stardust again some game
that meant or >> apparently bad I'm sorry the dude's I'm
sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry, Stardust. It's wrong for you to
call him a with little information. And B, you asked me why I
have a problem with you taking that information and saying what
you said. The reason why is because you literally admitted just
before that you did not have enough information. You took and
I knew that when you >> I'm not finished. I'm not messaged.
Let's finish. Yeah. First, >> the reason I was annoyed
is because this is happening not just with you, but it's with
people all over the space. They're grabbing information that
is not confirmed. It's like it's ex it's from all of these different
places and you're coming up with these. You're saying on your
stream that therefore you said it, Tom is a boy and I can't defend
him. Now, I read it. I'm not finished. >> I need to pull
up my audio levels cuz I have to turn some stuff down, but I'll
make sure. >> What's wrong with your contacts, man? I'm
not finished. I don't care if you're finished. I don't care because
you're wrong. Okay. What somebody said in that
repeated it. I repeat that. >> Why did I say it? Because
I repeated and I said I was like, "Oh yeah, that you know, but
like bro, are you wrong? What is wrong with you? Why can't you
just admit that you're wrong in
chill the out?" >> Mantis is employing the Tony tactic
here. You just announce that you've won or they've lost. Okay.
And then it's over for the other person. was probably the most
balanced person in covering the Tom and you are such a [__]
dick. You were wrong. >> Stardust is trying to Okay, hold
on.
>> I'm not wrong about that. >> Wait, Stardust is
just trying to approach us from the best of faith, right? Like,
just give her some of the >> I promise I was literally
the only person who was willing to give Tom any. I was the only
person who fought with >> I'm not saying I'm not saying
that you weren't good faith. >> Did you really? >> I'm
not saying that you haven't been saying fine if you're disappointed
with me, ma'am, but again, >> quick shout out for me there.
You have not provided a feasible solution to me as somebody who
does not [__] let me explain to you. Okay. I've tried
to explain to you why I'm disappointed and you will not accept
it. And that's fine if you don't want to accept why. Accept it.
I accepted that you're disappointed with me, man. I said that,
you know, I said already accept why. Do you accept with me? I
have a problem with your solution to this situation.
Do you accept why your situation is not feasible? It is not.
>> Do you accept why I'm disappointed? I understand why
you're disappointed. Yes, but your solution is [__]
>> I'm not talking about the solution. You wanted to bring
up the solution. I wanted to know why.
>> I I didn't I didn't bring up the solution. You asked
me that. >> This isn't the drags of Tom 10 at all. This
is so much better than that VOD we watched of Tom not answering
anything and like just watching the Zona VOD and not really saying
anything cogent or like intelligible. This is so much better.
I was I want to kill myself during that Tom VOD. This is way
better.
>> [__] about what you do now.
>> Shut up. Shut up. I I see. Do you understand why I asked
for everybody else in the space? >> But is there any new
info at all like that could help? >> Yeah. I mean like
I don't understand.
>> That's fine. It Okay. Can I just say something? I understand.
There's nothing coming from Tom's side, but that's important.
Do you understand why I think it's important to not important?
>> Hang on. I'm not done. Stardust, please let me finish
one sentence. Please. Do you understand why I'm upset that someone
would get up on stream and say he's there? Like, >> ain't
no way Mantis is calling out people for interrupting her, right?
She literally didn't let that Kylo guy get more than four words
out without screaming. And now she's like, Stardust, you got
to let me finish. Oh my god, you're immature. >> Like in
some way implying he's a boy and there's like misleading and
there's a relationship with women in his community and he's creepy
and therefore I cannot defend him. I didn't say he was creepy.
>> I didn't say he was creepy. >> I did not say he
was creepy. >> Okay, stop. You didn't say he was creepy,
but you said he was a [__] boy and he had like uh
misleading sass and he was women from his community. There was
like female problems in his community and therefore you couldn't
you are overexpanding this. I said that you are overexpanding
this. You are overexpanding this. So
you are overexpanding. Okay, fine. >> Stop. Okay. Yeah,
just say what you want to say. And after after you said all of
that, you said, "Therefore, I cannot defend Tom." And I think
it's weird for people. My point is I'm making a
>> No, I'm making a general point. Please, Stardust. Stop.
I'm making a general point about people who are saying these
statements and then they're saying things like, "Therefore, I
cannot defend Tom." Or, "At the moment, I would like to back
out." >> No, I said I'm not going to ostracize
>> I said, "I'm not going to ostracize >> I didn't
I didn't say you're canceling him. Stop. You're putting words
in my mouth. Okay. What is saying? You're not understanding her
feelings. You're not understanding her feelings. What is saying
that? >> But she's not understanding mine. Okay. What I
am said, what I'm saying, can I finish anything? Can I finish
one thing? >> Was Mantis even talking?
>> Okay. What is saying? You're not understanding her feelings.
You're not understanding her. >> Oh, it was food shops,
but it wasn't. >> But she's not understanding mine. Okay.
What I am what I'm saying. Can I finish anything? Can I finish?
>> She literally It was just Stardust talking and Mantis
starts screaming. Can I finish >> one thing?
Go ahead. >> Shut up, Stardust. >> Okay, go for another
10 minutes. >> 10 minutes? Are you [__] insane?
Okay, so you said all of that. You said you didn't want to defend
Tom, therefore. And I take issue with the fact that you are coming
to that conclusion like you cannot defend Tom. But none of the
evidence you've supplied. You've come to the conclusion that
you cannot defend Tom based off evidence that is not full. There's
no context there. You haven't heard from Tom. It's not fair to
you for you to get to that like conclusion. >> Give his
give his context. Tom and then what? You're going to say now
I can defend Tom. Do you think that's fair? >> No, we're
all We're all going to say that's probably not true based on
everything else Thomas said. That's also probably not true. >> [__]
put my reputation on the line. Yeah, I do want [__]
evidence to defend him. Are you [__] kidding me?
I already went and defended him. I He is not entitled to me defending
him. >> I'm not asking you to defend him. I'm just asking
you to not say that you want to defend him. >> Nobody in
this space Nobody in this space is entitled to me to go to bat
for them. If I'm going to go to bat for somebody, then I better
have good [__] evidence. Otherwise, yeah, I'm going
to stay out of it. I didn't say it was I said specifically I'm
not going to ostracize a guy, but I'm certainly not going to
go to >> She put her reputation on the line >> I
was just going to say she put her reputation on the line getting
in VC with me, guys. >> I'm not going to ostracize a guy,
but I'm certainly not going to go to bat for him and go fight
with Jilk again. The you said on stream today was a little bit
implicational and I didn't like it. >> Okay. Well, I took
it back later once you messaged me. >> So, you do feel
bad about saying it? >> Oh my god. No [__]
Sherlock. No [__] >> Wait, so you guys agree
with each other? Like Like what is the disagreement here? >> Go
to bat for him. Are you [__] kidding me? Wait, where's
the disagreement here?
My defense. >> Does anybody know where the disagree? >> Hold
on. What is this?
>> In the future. And if they try to keep saying you're
I mean like just is the one who's sitting on stream with all
of the Destiny female Destiny orders, right? All of the hot ones
and talking to them every night. So who's trying to get into
pants? That's my question. >> Well, that was his >> that
was my argument about Tom, by the >> Wait, so Stardust
isn't on the stream every night? What is she saying about
>> Uh, listen.
>> don't believe Stardust. Okay. >> No, I'm not.
I'm just saying. >> All right. We're not even
psycho. You're being a psycho. >> You agree. You agree
that just the way my point was to use you as an example of what's
happening in this space right now is that people are saying and
doing things that are implying things and then you find something
that nobody's entitled to. Nobody else has to go to bat for anybody.
But you because I said I'm not going to bat for him over something.
You have this huge problem with me. Go find other people who
are actually [__] going in on him hard. I was not
doing that. I just said I'm not defending him. you. I'm not asking
you to bet for him. I'm just asking you to leave out the [__]
when you don't know what you're talking >> I can't I don't
have a news team behind me, Mantis. I can't weed out the >> Oh,
sick boy. Sorry, that was a clip. Somebody gave me a clip. >> Well,
I just think it's weird that people are just going to talk and
then like carry on for an entire stream, leaving it hanging that
you've implied that he like misled someone and he was like assaulting
people in his community or something. Did I say no? Did I say
second because you're conflating all the bad faith actors with
Stardust when Stardust is just explaining her good faith perspective.
>> Oh, I understand Stardust. My point from the beginning
wasn't like what she did later or how she's like she's not taking
a side. It's fine that she doesn't take a side. I'm not asking
her to bet for >> Like like Stardust isn't from Spicy Chat.
In fact, she hates Spicy Chat. Like you are. You You are because
what you had a problem with was not me going in on Tom. It was
me saying why I'm not going to bat with him for him. Hang on.
Stop. Let me finish my problem. I will tell you my let me finish
what I'm saying. My the reason the reason like like I'm saying
you your critique is just wild to me is that you are coming at
me for not >> wait what what are you saying? Stop. Stop.
Are you saying stop them? Stop. Sorry. Watching chat pretty closely
cuz I'm scared my mic's going to [__] up again. are
act like because I said because I said that these are the reasons
why I have a problem going to bat for him that somehow I am so
much more responsible than everybody else when in reality I have
been the only person who's gone to bat for him and I I just all
I said was why I'm not going to bat for him anymore. I did not
condemn him. I said I'm not ostracizing him. So get [__]
That's what it is. I'm not entitled to it. He is not entitled
to it. Nobody in this space is >> that's not my critique.
Would you like to hear my critique? >> No, I don't want
to because >> Oh no. Tell me Mantis isn't gonna do the
Katie where where someone accurately describes exactly what she's
saying and she's gonna go, "No, no, no. That's not what I'm saying."
And then she's gonna reiterate exactly what the other person
just said. Tell me she's not going to do the Katie move.
>> My critique is not that like the conclusion you ended
up. >> But you you your problem is with me saying why I'm
not going to defend him. >> You're hurting Santa's feelings.
That's what's happening. >> Food chops. The reason why
>> you are not entitled to my defense. That's it. >> Are
you going to let me say why or not? >> No. You've already
explained it, ma'am. I don't need you to explain it further.
I get it. You feel entitled to me defending him. You feel entitled
to me defending you and you are not entitled to me defending
you. Thank you. >> Stardust, I don't want you to defend
him of what she did or like >> absolutely destroyed
>> defending him. >> The first ever recorded Stardust
W. What >> reason is because the why she decided she wouldn't
defend Tom, she pronounced >> I'm pretty sure Stardust
comes back at some point. why she didn't want to defend Tom was
because she's heard a lot of rumors and she's basically believing
them. And that's the problem I have. The problem I have is that
she said publicly on her stream that he's misleading people and
he's he's like dealing with people in females in his community
and she spread all of those rumors out and then she said that's
why I can't defend Tom. It's not fair. You can't just spread
rumors.
That's my problem. >> Okay. Um, Mantis, do you realize
that like for me, Stardust also said, "Hey, you know, I'm going
to distance from food shops because of the whole like I'm a thing."
Right. Um, now what I did was that I DM' her like you did and
I said, "Hey, you know, this is not >> Yeah, this is like
>> this is the dankst.
>> Stardust vs. The Kiwi Karen." >> So, the thing
is is that >> I feel
Can someone steal man position right now? Food drops. you should
advocate to get me on righteously counter man righteously countermantis
with an even stronger accent. I mean I don't know Chris Bliss.
Okay. I don't know. >> Yeah. Your your position is that
when Stardust is saying, you know, I heard from the grapevine
about all these things and it's all about like bad things about
you and Tom, right? Um you have a problem with that because it's
still proliferating it even though she's not giving it like a
full good faith, >> No. No. My problem is that she heard
from the greatness. She said on her stream and then she said
afterwards that's I just cannot defend Tom after all of this
like she believed it. >> Do you get it? >> Like yes.
Yes, I get it. But the thing is is that it's just >> that's
my point. >> Okay. But that's her kind of putting it out
there as her opinion. >> How long is this cancer? >> Uh
I'm just like chilling until people want to come in. I think
like there's people around if people want to come in. I don't
mind like pausing top 10 especially now that Stardust left. But
like I don't know. I wanted to talk about the twoman stuff. I
was hoping to talk about the two mad stuff with like a bunch
of people to have like some interesting back and forths, but
I'm just covering Tom 10 because nobody's >> Better just
separate the two, right?
that's all my point is is she should have separated. >> Hold
on. Let me let me can I just let me speak? I'm trying to be as
real as possible. Okay, please. So So what like what started
states is that she could have done a better job, right? where
she could have separated um oh yeah all this drama is going on
versus like that all that rumor stuff versus oh I'm just stepping
away from it because you know all this is too much for me right
if she meant if she meant spec stardust you're >> oh Stardust
rejoined oh no >> okay all right whatever here's the thing
is that here's how I perceive it is that right now Stardust just
seems like I'm going to go use the bathroom I'm going to step
away for a moment right that's from my perspective and then you
you have yeah but you have a problem with specifically how start
it right that's that's what you have a problem is how she said
it, not what she actually believes. Right. Okay. Thank God. Okay.
I understand. Yes. Yeah. >> Yes. I have a problem with
how she portrayed it live stream publicly. Yes. >> Okay.
Uh again, you messaged me and I took it back on stream. >> Okay.
That's fine. You took it back. But we we got into this argument
because all I was saying was I had a problem with how you said
it. We got into the argument as you argued with me on it. >> I
know. We got into this argument because I asked you for your
solution. It is good solution. The solution is here's what I
said on stream. >> Start us up. My solution is very simple.
You need to hear it. My solution is wait for everything before
you say like that. >> The difference is is that when I
said on stream, I've heard that Foods has been calling herself
a PDF file. Food shop messaged me and and she said, "No, that
hasn't been happening for several weeks." And I said, "Oh, okay
then. That's fine. Whatever. We're fine now. >> banging
pots on this stream right now. What the [__] just
happened?" Oh, she walks away.
>> What the [__] is happening? I said on >> Start
us up. My solution is very simple. You need to hear it. My solution
is wait for everything before you say [__] like >> The
difference is is that when I said >> No, I won't wait.
I'll immediately conclude. Okay. With appropriate caveats to
let people know where I could be wrong. But I will immediately
conclude cuz that's fun. It's fun to conclude. >> Dream.
I heard. >> You just have to conclude and also say, "But
I could be wrong and here's where I could be wrong." >> Foods
has been calling herself a PDF file. food shop messaged me and
and she said, "No, that hasn't been happening for several weeks."
And I said, "Oh, okay then. That's fine. Whatever. We're fine
now. We're cool. I'm on her stream. I'm still chilling with her.
I'm not ostracizing her." And >> I know you're good. I'm
not saying you're not good. >> I didn't want to defend
somebody because I don't
>> Okay, fine. >> Stop. You're not getting my point.
She didn't get my point. My prescription was just can she not
say XY Z and then explain that as the reason why she's not defending.
Like I feel like it's I know Stardust is good. My point is she
said he's a boy. He's like apparently he's been misleading someone.
Apparently he's been doing XY Z and therefore I cannot defend
him anymore. >> Okay, sure. But okay, so if she's like
if she's proven wrong later, then just let that happen, right?
Then she's the one that looks doing that, right? Like >> it's
[__] weird. It's weird. >> You have to give
her room to look. Okay, >> tops. It's She asked me what
my prescription was. >> Oh my god. She just won again.
No shot. The full context. >> I mean, that's what I'm feeling
right >> Neutrality. That's all I say. What is wrong with
you guys? >> Yeah. What's wrong with you? >> Maybe
Maybe don't use skewed information as a reason for your neutrality.
>> Don't use just what other people have said. You mean
>> Yes. Just be just be neutral. You don't have to use
like narratives that have been spun that you haven't actually
clarified. Just be telling your audience
>> Some dude donated to say get WD40. >> Tom is a
[__] boy and that he's misled
Mantis. Mantis. Mantis Mantis, if anybody if if anybody if one
of my friends told me, "Hey, by the way, one of our mutuals was
like crazy and and whatever the I showed them a bunch of clips
and whatever the [__] I would do that, too. I would
already go, you know what? I'm going to step away. I'm going
to, you know, it doesn't look good and I know what I'm looking
at." Right? You have to understand position, right? >> I
don't think that's unreasonable. >> Actually, I am being
reasonable here. I am saying that food shops uh sorry, that Stardust
is allowed to be neutral. Can you please understand that before
I move >> Yeah, I understand that. Okay. Like, okay, wait,
hold on. I got to watch >> just like all you have to say
is you understand. Like, do you get do you understand that? >> Yeah.
Okay. No, I understand your frustration, right? >> Oh,
I'm an idiot. I was about to ask, does does this person just
have two computers? Like, why is there a second computer set
up over there? But it is uh very clearly a closet with a mirror
on >> okay. No, no, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop. Do you
understand that what I'm saying at the base level is that it's
okay for for Star to be neutral? >> Start says she's been
neutral from the
I know that's fine. >> She just doesn't sound neutral.
That's it. That's what you have a problem with. >> I have
a Yes. I have a problem with someone who says they're neutral
and then doesn't sound like adult when they call someone a
private like, "Hey, by the way, I don't appreciate the way you
sounded and this is why, right?" And then bam, you're >> Okay.
I was Let me just clarify one thing. I think I was relatively
neutral on this from the beginning. I defended Tom because I
don't think that him looking at an Instagram page on stream has
like any uh anything to do with him being a sexist. I don't think
it proves he's a sex. I honestly don't think it's that big of
a deal. Who gives a like somebody looked at somebody's Instagram?
>> But I did also I was neutral. I'm not on Tom's side.
I just thought that that was >> debating it. Okay. >> Now,
what I had critiques of with Tom is him going on Wick's panel
with >> What are you doing? >> Uh End Times memes.
Thank you for the donation. super chat 10 bucks
>> Oh, I'm gonna pause right now and just say like guys
also don't forget uh I really would appreciate the monetary support,
right? Uh subscribers on kick actually like you subscribing yourself
would be amazing. Uh super chats are helpful. Streamlabs donations
are better. The Streamlabs link is in both of my pages, right?
Streamlabs donations of $5 or up get right as TTS on screen.
So yeah, give me money. Just give me money. Okay, I have to I
have to ebe now. I have to do it. I have to ebeg. I've been I've
been instructed to ebe as hard as I can. You get ad revenue.
Um
I get ad revenue, but most of my streams get demonetized.
So, I don't really get ad revenue after the stream finishes.
I think I get about 30 to $40 of ad revenue per stream if it's
like six to six to eight hours. About 30 to $40 of ad revenue.
>> You are safe. You are safe. Oh my god. >> It is
okay for you to be neutral.
>> And the only thing that was new today is that I said
I'm not going to >> I don't want to hear it. I get what
you're saying. I don't need to hear it. My point stand. You were
just being so manipulative. I You were saying, "Oh, it's okay
for her to be neutral." As if I wasn't already neutral. I am.
The only thing I said >> okay for you to be neutral, but
you >> The only thing I said on my stream that was different
was that I was not going to go to bed for him anymore. That >> No,
no, it's not the only thing you said. You called him a [__]
boy. >> I did call him a [__] boy. I said that's
why I'm >> so that's not neutral. You [__]
>> Oh my god. I said I'm not ostracizing him. Holy [__]
>> You don't even know if he's a [__] boy.
You're just lying. >> No lying. I have people telling me
that he's a [__] boy. Like holy [__]
>> No, you don't know. You have no conf you have confirmation
from [__] bad. >> It doesn't It literally doesn't
matter. You just argue about the behaviors. Why Why do people
get so hung up on labels?
Labels are like I don't know so pointless. It's like, why do
you think he's a Why not just ask that question instead of screaming
he's not a like just ask why she thinks he's a It's so easy.
It's so easy. >> Bad actors. That's my point. You're all
bad actors. They're all bad actors. >> I just I want to
know who's a bad actor. I just I just want to know what
>> Prove Prove it. Prove it. >> Wait, but because
I'm certainly not neutral now. Holy. >> Can I ask you a
question? >> No. Prove that Tom is a This is my problem.
You guys are pulling out allegations and I don't like it. >> Is
really that big of a deal? Like holy >> because you're
sex really that big of a deal? I don't know. >> In the
middle of
where Tom is being slandered for all of the stuff you want to
add to the >> you want to add to it by calling him friends.
Like are you kidding me? I'm not calling him alter like what?
>> Yeah, but you're saying that he what you're saying when
you say is you're saying he's playing multiple women at one time.
He's not. That's not a good thing to play into in the middle
of a controversy where Chub's community is saying that he has
a misleading like thing with SAS and then he's cheating on SAS
with me. >> Are you sure? >> That's not okay. >> Are
you definitely sure that he was not doing that?
>> Okay. What if he's lying to you? >> Yes, exactly.
>> I have so many I just don't see like as an issue every
DM. I've seen every DM. >> Okay. Did you see the Wait,
did you see >> Actually, just so you know, Mantis, um or
sorry, just so you know, Kilo, when when people date, they sign
a contract and they can't lie to each other. Okay. So,
she could he couldn't possibly be lying to her. It's literally
impossible.
>> One where he told Sassifas that you had never sent him
a video the day that the nude leaked. >> Yes. Because he
doesn't want to tell Sassifras about our private situation cuz
he doesn't want our private life being leaked.
>> We don't want to tell people about our private life.
Why did you act so incredulous when I suggested that he was trying
to protect himself against
>> Because that is a narrative that you're spinning when
actually the narrative is he doesn't want to tell people about
our relationship. We want to keep it private. What is wrong with
you? You want to believe a different narrative, but the narrative
is we want to be private and you guys will not let us be private.
You want to spin a narrative.
>> What is wrong with you, Kilo? >> I I don't want
to spin a narrative. When you told me >> you are you are
really spinning a >> Mantis, pump the brakes, Mantis. When
you told me when I asked you Mantis, whether those did you leave?
>> Oh, did the content just leave? >> Mantis. I sent
Mantis a message. When >> Mantis will be back. Mantis will
be >> Tom accidentally pulled up a nude on his stream.
I sent a message to Mantis and I asked her, you know, like um
I'm hearing a rumor um that uh let me see so she doesn't act
like I'm like lying again. Let me see where it is. Um >> yeah.
Okay. Wait. Starters, do do you get like her frustration though?
Right. I get her frustration, but she moves her she twists and
she moves things like so. Okay. How so? How how does she how
does she twist and move things? >> Because my initial thing
with her was I was asking her what is her solution and she gave
me a solution that is not a >> Okay. What does that always
come back
>> like word for word? I I I can't remember word for word
but
history of humankind has someone lied to their partner. >> So
the thing is like like Mantis would have preferred if you said
something along the lines of hey you know I've heard some bad
things about Tom. All right. Um I don't know what to make of
it just now and I just want to step away from you know all this
situation until it's over but I'm still going to review it. Right.
>> What's done? That's fine. What is done is done. She
messaged me. She said, "Hey, like she said, I'm disappointed
you don't have something like that. You don't have all the context
for this that you're saying this. You're perpetuating narrative
or something like that along those lines." Um, hold on. Right.
Fine. I will I will fine. I will I will at the end of my stream.
I'll make sure that I say um uh you know, I say otherwise, right?
I'll I'll say that I you know, I realize I don't have all the
information on this. That's what I did. >> Yeah. So So
you basically >> I'm uh I'm probably just going to start
skipping until I see Mantis come back. Okay. You might just end
up skipping through the rest of this video.
>> I had this problem with me perpetuating. >> We'll
find Mantis and then we'll go back like 90 seconds to see. We'll
go back 90 seconds to see what was said precisely that triggers
her to come back.
>> I think these are all indications of, you know, you
being trying to be more good faith, right? >> I was trying
to be on good faith. I wouldn't say that I was completely on
Tom's side. I do. >> You got 5 seconds. >> You're
playing optics and I'm >> Oh, there she is. >> It's
okay. >> There she is.
There
>> situation. Yeah, but um I don't have evidence to say
he is a sexist. So, >> or an abuser, right? >> All right.
Like if you if you leak somebody's nudes to um I think the reason
she's frustrated with uh the thing isn't because like a problem
but
I called myself a a bunch of times but obviously has a connotation
and using a
term with Tom during this whole thing about him having negative
negatively connotated interactions with you know like bad interactions.
I think it's just yeah I think she a little >> Yeah. And
again, just to reiterate, I don't think Tom is a second fest.
Um, do you think he mishandled the situation? Yeah. But, um,
I don't have evidence to say he's a second fest. So, or an abuser,
right? >> All right. Look, if you if you leak somebody's
nudes to 200 people and then your response is, "Hey, um, you
know, that's going to happen when you're a Kum online." You know
what I'm saying? What are you going to do? That's kind of [__]
crazy. That's kind of [__] crazy behavior. >> I
thought that was like obviously mistake, right? >> Yeah.
I don't think that he nearly accepted the email like responsibility.
He almost made it sound like it's like, "Well, that's going to
happen." >> Um, yeah. I don't know. But I'm going to go
now because it is almost 2 a.m. here so I meant to go to sleep
like forever ago. So, have a good one, guys. >> Yeah, no
problem. Hold on. >> Do you have anything for me before
I go? Uh, food. Um, no. >> Wait, didn't Mantis joined immediately
when Stardust left? >> Oh, look at that.
uh, okay. Listen, she didn't say a single word, but Ninetails
was in here. Okay, dude.
>> 5 seconds. >> Okay, Mantis, just take the rest
of the night off. Okay, I just It's all good. >> Well,
I mean, it's not really like I'm kind of annoyed with people
platforming people who don't have >> Mantis is not taking
the rest of the night off. She's here all night now. >> Have
full information and they say stuff. Uh, wouldn't this whole
argument be over if Stardust just owned up to the fact that she
was just drama farming? Like, why not just bite the bullet? I
mean, she could even say like, "This was my impression and once
you like reminded me of this, I changed my mind." Like, oh man,
I just don't. None of these people are willing to be wrong. Like,
maybe I just misinterpret how viewers act. But like, if you're
just wrong on something, like, if I'm just wrong on something,
are people going to leave? Like, nobody actually cares if you're
wrong. Like, as long as you can say, "This is why I thought this.
Oh, I have some new piece of information. here's how my opinion
changed. Like, but all of these people think that if they're
proven wrong on something, they're like, all of their viewers
are going to leave. Just like, admit you're wrong. It's okay.
You can just be wrong. >> And you're you're like backing
them up and saying, >> "Being wrong is awesome. >> Why
don't you see it from these people's perspective? They've only
seen like half the information, but you should like understand
where they're coming from with half the information. Why are
you like this food shops? Why are you like
>> Why are you like this? >> What What is your specific
intention? I just told you. Are you dumb? >> Okay, it seems
as though your specific contention is that I bring on Stardust
who is saying things, right? As an example, but here's the thing.
>> A lot of people, it's not just today. I've watched I've
seen it.
>> Okay. Well, who? Just just give an >> You bring
on Lynn. You bring on people who like speculate. You bring on
stardust like today. >> Hold on with Lynn to be to be very
fair. Okay. I during that I was like, "Hey, you know, there's
speculation, right?" >> Oh, yeah. Well, why today were
you like explaining how Stardust's like motive was rational?
Please explain. >> So, like we all agreed Stardust is bad
when it comes to, you know, saying things off the bat and she
acknowledged it as such when you DM'd her, right? And she was
willing to correct it at the end of her stream. That's fine.
>> That's not okay. That's fine. I don't understand why.
Okay, this is like a Zongu argument where she's like, "Oh, no.
Well, I'm super public with how [__] how much of
a I am. I've Oh, I definitely leaked DMs in Spicy. I definitely
leaked their relationship in Spicy. Therefore, I can like avoid
all accountability. What are you talking about? I'm allowed to
get up here and say, "Hey, it's cool that you admitted you did
it, but you still did it, cunt." My relationship and spicy and
then confirmed it with my ex. Yeah, but that's like verification
through news >> that's like a totally different thing like
leaking somebody's rel like you're doing something like that's
intentionally malicious. It's way different from saying here's
my perception. Here's like what I think. Here's like my immediate
off-the-cuff take. Like it's completely different from saying,
"Okay, you're taking an action I don't like." >> My ex.
That's weird. I'm allowed to get up here and say to Stardust,
"Hey, it's fine that you said later, oh, by the way, guys, I
didn't really realize like I don't have the full context, blah
blah >> I guess we don't know how Stardust said it to stream.
I did imply a lot and then use that as a reason for why I defended
like said I couldn't defend Tom. I'm allowed to get up here and
say a lot of that is wrong. Just because they say they did stuff
doesn't mean it's okay and it's wild food shops that you're going
to sit here and tell me that these are going to go out there
and say, "Oh, oh yeah, I leaked DMs in spicy, >> but because
I told you it's fine."
>> Yeah. At the start, I might have got things wrong. I
might have implied a lot for a 12hour stream to my entire audience.
But at the end where no one was around, I clarified. >> Okay,
hold on. Can I talk that? Wait, hold on. Can I talk? Okay, so
I
think that there's a lot. >> Can we all agree on a holiday
where we all get off social media one day and touch grass? Would
that not be based? I don't know. My kill >> narrative going
around. I think that
>> Okay, can I finish? Okay, >> you bought into them
too. I watched you for the last four days. >> Okay, please
let me just finish. Okay.
>> not just her eyes, >> I made a lot of conclusions
and etc. Because again, I was going off of incomp Okay, hold
on. To say that there's no evidence is entirely inaccurate, right?
>> because there is evidence. Sure. Incomplete evidence.
Sure. Sure. Okay. Sure. Sure. Sure. Sure. Sure. Sure. Incomplete
evidence, right? Like I said before, right? So, incomplete evidence
and I acknowledge that, you know, that's irresponsible already,
right? So the whole thing is that hey, you know, I acknowledge
I did something wrong, but that >> this is where my initial
conversation, the very first time I talked to Tom, this is where
it broke down was he was just like he was mad that I didn't have
like DM evidence of him flirting with some mentally ill woman
in DMs and then also said he was af
um I have like circumstantial evidence and I'm forming an opinion
based on that. But that doesn't mean that every single way that
I am doing this situation is wrong. >> No one is saying
that. No one is saying that. The problem with people like you
is you cannot admit that you did something wrong. >> You're
doing it right now. You're saying people like you. You are actually
painting me as the same as somebody like Queen as somebody like
Spicy Chatters or anything like that. But I'm not. You know I'm
not. >> Yes. Because you are. >> Okay. No, >> you've
done the same thing. You've taken the same narratives from the
same people. the reason why you came to the conclusions you did
and you said it's incomplete narratives. I'm not saying that
you're as bad faith and you're pushing the same narratives to
the end, but you used the information from those people to come
to your incomplete narratives and talk about it on stream for
the last 3 days and that has perpetuated rumors. Are you [__]
insane food shops? >> Yeah, being in your Fifi isn't bad.
Perpetually canceled. As long as you know like, hey, as long
as you can state exactly why you think something and then accept
criticism from other people like about your opinion, that's totally
fine. That's literally just having a >> Okay, like I said
before, all right, I'm saying is that I can acknowledge I did
something wrong, which we both agree already, right? We acknowledge
I did something wrong, but
>> going forward apologizing. >> Do not say that.
You're not allowed to say but. You You're not allowed to say
but. I'm literally retracting your butt and I'm saying the butt
negates your apology. So, do not say but. You say you did something
wrong and then show me you've changed. Moving forward. Full
>> Nuance. There's nuance in presentation,
>> No, there's not. You're playing optics and I'm not playing
that game. Just say you did something wrong.
>> What is happening?
What the Why are you doing this?
>> All of you have played into the narrative. You played
into it and you perpetuated and you're not willing to apologize.
Yeah, this is this is a food shop, so
us
fine, [__] I don't care. >> Uh, why does Mantis
have to be so dumb? She'd be like super based. Yeah, right, Tarni.
She'd actually be super based if she wasn't this dumb. >> Why
are you sitting here and taking this? Why are you letting this
person talk call you these names? What is going >> Because
I don't because I don't care. Okay, that's why. >> Okay,
fair. Fair enough. Yeah, now I've >> because I think because
I think that, you know, if you are going to slam me and you know,
I just don't let these ad homs get to me whatsoever. I don't
care. >> yeah, fair enough. I feel the same way. It's not
it's this is not helping Mus.
But, uh, Joo Tube in the chat says, "Experts in optics and communication."
Yeah, Food Shops is completely the expert in optics and communication.
Like, we all know that, right?
>> It's definitely not the case. Right. This is why like
I'm trying to I feel as though when I was criticizing Tom, right?
I feel as though that I was coming from a place of good faith.
Um, I feel as though that um I have advocated for Tom's good
character. Yeah. Sure. Sure. So, here's the thing, right? Is
that I advocated for Tom's character a
>> I'm saying you went like you're getting me wrong. Can
Can you please like hear what I'm saying? >> No, you're
painting me You're painting me like a a Chud Orbiter, right?
When I'm not That's an insult to me because these people are
slimy, right? I agree with you. >> Yeah. Listen, >> there's
literally only one Chud orbiter. Okay. There's literally only
one. >> That's a That's a category of one person. Who are
you making fun of? We all know who you're making fun of. food
jobs. Just say the name. I got to treat him like Voldemort. Just
say the name. >> My point is, even though you guys may
not realize it right now and you're going to defend it to the
nth degree because of all your streams and like how neutral you've
tried to be, blah blah blah, my point is all of the narratives
that you've used to like spin your content into. All of the narratives
you've pushed have come from no full context and all bad faith
actors. So, it's fine to make content on that, but I'm just telling
you, you haven't got the full context. And it's kind of weird
that you like say things on your streams and like push narratives
and encourage like chitchat about narratives. >> No, there's
only like one person in Chud's community who streams that's like
an adjacent community of his. Yeah, there's only one person.
>> You haven't had the full context. I'm telling you from
a person in the middle of a like scandal that I'm seeing people
around me take information from not good actors and you're using
it and you've like said things and I know you didn't mean to
and I know there's no bad intentions but I'm watching in real
time people I did not expect to be so bad faith take bad faith
narratives and work off that. >> And like you say things
and you like supply narratives and I'll okay
you're not good people. You're bad people and you do bad content.
>> Are you just here to preach or are we having a conversation?
>> Dude, yeah, we should we got to get we got to get Mantis
back in the server. Okay, because like as much as I as much as
I don't like Mantis, I will admit foods had 100 viewers covering
this and I don't think she ever gets above like 20 or 30 most
of the time. This is like the biggest her stream's ever been.
Okay, Mantis
is content. Okay, I hate to say it. I hate to admit it, but I
invited her into my server in the first place because she is
unfortunately content. Okay.
>> I see I see one narrative from one place. I see another
narrative from another place and I'm going to be like, "Okay,
here are the available evidence that we have. I think this narrative
is stronger." Right? >> And I think that when you know
at the >> why is it stronger? Tell me why though. I want
to know why. And if you say the like mess like i.e. the most
like the numbers that are saying it. >> No, you want to
understand where I'm coming from, right? So, I'm trying to explain.
Why is it the most Why is it the most >> I'm just trying
to explain myself, but you're not hearing me out. Okay, >> I'm
asking you why. Please explain. >> Okay, so yes, it could
be irresponsible that I drew conclusions to one. I don't think
Mantis won. >> However, I would say that >> but listen,
Mantis won optically. Interesting. Interestingly, and ironically,
the one thing Mantis says she doesn't care about is optics. And
that's the only way she won was optically by yelling that she
won. also yelling that she was muting Stardust instead of listening
to her. She's actually kind of based. >> Okay, once I present
a narrative and even though I am incredibly biased
bias against people like whatever, at this point we have seen
other people >> Zia um like uh Becket like
bad information from good information. And there's a reason why
they're running
>> a narrative, right? They're running with a narrative
not because they're missing out on information, but because but
because they see one side is stronger than the other. I'm just
telling you what the perspective is. That's it. Does that make
sense? >> Okay. I I know the perspective. I'm not I've
literally watched everyone for the last 4 days. I know the perspective.
I would just hope that people in a certain sphere of this internet
would have more critical thinking abilities, but they don't.
Hankmore does. Hankmore has been great. Look at it. >> Mantis
does not have critical thinking abilities. This is the most probably
>> played Switzerland. None of you have. >> Oh well,
people shame Switzerland, right? Like I don't think that's the
best example. They're Switzerland is dope them. >> Switzerland
is dope and you for jobs. You're just playing content games cuz
you're a as well. And when you did your lolly [__]
I should have jumped on the train or I called you a because you
I defended you and I >> when I was on the lolly [__]
When I was on the lolly, right, I acknowledge that's wrong of
me to be on the lolly [__] Right. Oh, now now you
acknowledge it. I spent three weeks defending you. You're an
idiot. >> No, I have been. Okay. I just like >> Sorry,
I just want to say real quickly. >> So, you you thought
she might have been a and you were defending her. I don't understand
what the point is here. Either you didn't think she's a you defended
her or you didn't think she's a and you defended her. You either
did the right thing or you did something like heinous.
But food chops, if she thinks whatever she thinks about Tom,
she's just saying it. Like it's a completely different argument.
Yeah. Yeah. Those like food chops isn't lying as far as I >> Quickly,
neutrality doesn't mean that you don't have an opinion on specific
>> That's fine. No, you're allowed to like I've said a
million times, Stardust, you're allowed to be neutral and have
an opinion. I just want your opinion to be based in some sort
of fact. And you have >> So you're comparing food to Okay.
So to somebody who's like extremely bad faith is just you're
being bad faith like at this point like >> how please you
just you literally just like did debate rode me and you said
nothing. How >> how you do you honestly think that food
shops is equivalent to somebody who is purposely spreading false
narratives.
>> I think that you guys are not purposely ever spreading
false narratives. But I would like to >> quick rundown
on what we're watching. So Mantis went on Foo stream and totally
like spurked out about Tom to Stardust and some other people
for a while and it's pretty funny. Okay, she is losing it. She's
losing it. >> Stand here and tell you that you are implicitly
spreading them. You don't even know. >> Disney host said
Krontos. Ouch. I mean Corantos is based. I I like Corantos. I
think if Kantos streamed with any regularity, he could become
like a really big streamer. I I think he's very funny. I think
if he was if he just literally wasn't like a devout Muslim or
like RP like role playing as a devout Muslim, I think he would
do a lot better. But >> no, you're doing it. But you do
it because you're so obsto.
>> I mean, we can check that out after. But I'm going to
uh I'm going to wait. I'm not going to cut Krontos' content and
go cover it instantly cuz that's like his content. If he's got
like leaks or unique information, that's actually pretty cool
>> that you do it and that's your reason for why you do
it. The reason why you are neutral is because Tom is apparently
>> No, there's no there's no audience capture here. Hates
me in this space, homie. Like, no. >> Then why Stardust?
Would you like say the reason why I'm not defending Tom is because
I've heard all these fake >> Um because >> you're
a [__] >> Do I think it's a work ethic thing
with Krontos? Uh a little bit. I think he's also like maybe he's
taking a real hard run at his uh university stuff. I thought
he was kind of like messing around. he just wanted to go back
and stream like from Malaysia, but maybe he's actually taking
like a really hard serious run at his his masters or whatever.
There's the argument here that Tom is essentially Israel in the
sense that his side of the story hasn't been released.
Gold Tom report. Uh, no. Tom's story has been released. The problem
is that he's released it like five times and there have been
like provable lies in every time essentially. So now they're
saying, "Oh, well, you don't know like Tom's side of the story."
And it's like, "Well, no, Tom gave multiple sides of the story,
and they were all lies, so now none of us actually care." >> Because
you're a That's why you're >> Okay, hold on. Starts
and is willing to make corrections on stream. Like, I don't see
where the >> because the the problem is it's fine for her
to fain ignorance. It makes sense. She's actually she has no
brain cells. So if she says, "Oh, I didn't know." That makes
sense. But the problem is this morning she said XY Z and that's
why I can't defend Tom. So if you're gonna be be in the right
location not defend him. I look I didn't say I didn't go out
of my way to condemn him. Like all I said is that >> I'm
not saying that you're moving to Gold Close. Engage with my argument.
You
He has no brain. I'm engaging with her in the specific way and
she cannot >> Alternate if you're in love. I've heard she's
pretty easy in DM. So maybe you should slide in.
The reason what if I said okay hold on mantis what if I said
that you saying that starts has no brains came from queen what
if I said that huh wouldn't that discredit everything that you're
saying no the reason why I'm saying is that you're saying that
I came from poisonous >> shut up the reason why I'm saying
shut up the reason why I'm saying status has no brains is because
I'm telling her the reason why I think there's a problem and
she cannot engage she's like keeps moving the goalpost like I
don't have to have a side I can be neutral I'm not saying you
can't be neutral I'm saying the reason why you publicly announced
you're neutral is because you said you have a problem with Tom's
behavior and you gave off a list list of things that were an
fake problem. You publicly said the reason why I cannot defend
Tom is because you think there is an issue with like misleading
people in his community and females in his community. You're
a liar. You said that and you're a >> Are you not a female
in his community,
>> Yes. And there are no problems between me and >> I
see how I got Did you see how I got Destiny to react to August
being mad about the podcast? Why was August mad about the podcast?
August wasn't mad about the podcast at all. >> A Yeah.
>> Yeah. Okay. >> So, what the [__] are
you talking about? >> He is having relationships with >> I
might have tried to a little bit in DG chat and I might have
misrepresent. I might have said something that is kind of true,
but I might have said it in a way that would have pissed people
off. Okay. Oh, you made it up too. Okay. >> in his community
and he actually
is that not a problem. leaking something of a female in his problem.
>> I don't think it's a problem enough for you to announce
that he's a on your >> Wait, which she took back which
she has apologized for. I don't know why you keep bringing that
up. >> She apologized for it later and then she came on
the stream tonight defending why she admit it. Admit it admit
you
asked you for a solution and I said your solution isn't feasible
and now I am getting evidence that uh that you know he might
be a so I mean you know what you know. >> Wait, wait, put
the evidence up. What is the evidence? doubling down. She's doubling
down right now like a >> No, she said she had evidence.
That's >> I'm getting messages. So, yeah. >> Oh my
god. >> Oh yeah. Leak him then, you stupid >> What
are we watching? We are watching Mantis, which is the girl who
was eating Tom Foolery and she's defending Tom Foolery from some
random accusations. Not totally sure. Like Stardust apparently
called Tom a or something. Apparently,
uh how do I go through this? So Tom had an a producer headmod
who it appeared like from DMs that she leaked that he was kind
of had like an e- relationship with. Brontos is leaking the full
Mitch fight video. Okay, I'm sorry. I lied that I wasn't going
to go check it out. I got to I got to see this. Okay, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry if that's actually true. Okay, hold on. I got this
up on the other monitor. Okay, if the actual video is there,
Mantis, do you think this helps? I will watch the video if you
actually watch the video. >> I am like this. I am like
this. I'm not going to pretend I'm help. Do you think this is
helps you? Like, do you think any of this is is is helping you?
>> Okay. I'm sorry. I just got to watch the one clip. I
won't cover any of his reactions. Nothing like that. Okay. >> Oh,
let me increase the volume for you guys. Let me let me increase
the volume for you guys. >> You can almost see everything
that's being said like 110%. So, it's going to be louder. It's
going to be louder. All right. All right. Let's see. >> No,
no, no. It was Sassifras who was the
>> You can hear them talking. You can hear M saying you've
ruined my life. You can >> Mitch just going in on him.
>> Says suck my dick repeatedly. You
>> says he asked for help. >> I have your back. You
need to admit you were a [__] douchebag.
>> I had your back. But you need to admit that you were
a douchebag. Clearly. >> Clearly there's some tension going
on behind you. privy to probably I >> I'm not going to
listen to Q's analysis. You want to listen to Kantos' analysis,
you can go to his stream. I don't want to steal a How did he
get it? Apparently Zezy, who was in chat earlier, apparently
Zezy said that he hooked up uh Mitch and Kantos
had this. >> So yeah, this is not very different from what
we all assumed, right? That basically they stopped. They were
going to be yelling at each other. There's going to be a fight
coming. I guess what we're looking for is just how badly Mitch
is baiting it, right? We're just trying to figure out. Why are
you so professional about being a drama farmer? Is it some Canadian
[__] Maybe. Clearly, there's a cut, right? This is
what was made available to everybody on Twitter. This is what
we've seen. >> Trash again. You said you could take me
seven times. You didn't listen to yourself. You're drunken on
cocaine. I had to talk a treat me like [__] You
all you can say [__] you. >> Shout out Fussy.
>> If all you do is say [__] you. You picked
two. >> He's going to He's going to milk that robot twice.
>> You You said Come on. You pulled me out of the car.
You said, "Let's go." >> You can't say.
>> You willing to [__] fight. >> Hold
on. He says, "You pulled me out of the car. You said let's go
again. We don't have access to that foot footage. We don't We
don't have that." >> I've asked I've asked Mitch. I was
like, "We need that footage. We need that footage." But he says,
"I don't have access to it. I don't have access to >> That's
a lie. >> I've asked around. I've looked around. I've spoken
to the neighbors. I've spoken to everybody. >> But apparently
Elena is in good standing with the HOA over there and whatnot.
>> Therefore, like she came to them and she got the footage
first. At least according to Mitch. >> Wait, who got the
footage first? >> Go ahead and keep watching. And by the
way, this is them like watch. >> There's nothing new. No,
no, no. >> Is crazy by the way cuz these are still yelling
at each other and they're driving off. You can hear >> you
just got back in the car with them after getting this kicked
out of them. That's funny.
would have been so much more bass if Miz had just driven away.
Beat the [__] out of him, drive away. What are we
still watching this for? Krontos
speak.
That's it. That's it. Now, mind you. Mind you, mind you. >> Mitch
says he does not have >> He does say it. I just want to
see if we >> the footage in its totality. >> He has
to say who has it. >> People accused him of editing. >> He
100% edited it. >> The footage. People accuse him of cutting
out the part where he pulls out Miscuit from the car, he starts
the altercation. That's what people accuse him of. That's what
people accuse him of. But he said, and when we were talking,
cuz I told you we were talking for like an hour. >> Spit
it out. >> Told me, I'm at fault. I'm at fault. >> I'm
the one who started the altercation. I'm the one who went up
to him. I'm the one who was talking. I was drunk as I was angry.
We were going back and forth. We were arguing so much prior to
leaving the house. He was like, "It's on me. It's my fault."
>> I'm good now. If you guys want to watch more of that,
that's fine. Oh [__] I left this running. Go back
just a minute. But yeah. Okay. So, is Mitch really going to be
on Keeper Kick? I mean, Mitch is super close friends with Kelly.
I would imagine Kelly could have introduced them. He didn't say
who introduced them, but like I know Kelly's super close with
Mitch and Kelly was just arguing that uh it she was just arguing
with me last night that it wasn't okay for Mitch to get the kicked
out of him no matter how much he was provoking.
I thought that was interesting. I think there's absolutely a
limit on how much somebody can provoke. You said so on the stream
today that Mitch would be on Keeper Kick. Okay, you should invite
him later on for a talk. His won't unless he gets an invite.
I mean, I could invite him on. I don't know if he'll come on.
Let me see if he'll I'll shoot a message right now. just typing.
Oh, I can't message him. He's not my friend. He's loser, dude.
I don't know if I blocked or something, but I tried messaging
him. Someone else would have to message him. I tried it. Okay,
I tried it. I also just touched my mic and moved it. So, if that
[__] it up, it did not. I am not really down with
more Tom, guys. I think we've got we've squeezed all of the uh
all the [__] out of the stone here. Yeah, I know
both of you guys know him in DFO75. Uh Msk is now the Miz. Um
yeah, Mitch was on kick. Mitch is on kick now. What about the
mantis tent? Well, I don't know how much more mantis is here.
We'll listen to the end of what Mantis has to say. Okay. >> Something.
Can I share something real quick? Real quick. Okay. >> All
right. >> Somebody just sent this to me. Okay. I'm going
to share it in. >> Oh, right. Stardust had some >> here.
Okay. Foods, feel free to put this on screen. >> Check
it out. Yeah. Give me a second. >> Oh, when is Vos dropping
his response? He said a few days. So, I would guess at least
another day or two. >> Okay. Hold on. She left She left
the cough, but hold on. Give me a second. >> Turn back
into Karantos. He's about to drop another clip. I hate you guys
so much. I'll just keep this up on the other monitor so that
I know. Need another clip. Is this just Misk talking about stuff
on stream? >> Clip murder. God damn. Is the clip mirror
not going to work? Okay, thank you. This be day of stop being
racist and watch Krontos. It just feels to like steal from him,
right? To just like rebroadcast what he's watching.
Q has nothing. It's like Tom. Uh that's a that's a bad it's a
bad association.
Now listen, I'll leave it up to your interpretation as to why
this clip is significant,
but I'll just clear something up. It's not because he's on drugs.
It's not because he's on drugs. The reason why this clip is support
is not because he's on drugs. That's not what the claim is. That's
not what the claim is. That's not what the claim is. >> Hey,
he's weaving a whole narrative for Mitch here. He's carrying
mad water for Mitch right now. >> Oh, I still What you
want, little [__] Message me. What you want? What
you want? What you want? >> He added me. Anyways, he said
that he wants to be on Kicker Keith and he's open to people like,
you know, having a back and forth as long as he's able to provide
his evidence. I was like, "My guy, you've got the platform.
You can hop on. We could talk, but we're not going to do the
whole, you know, just save space." Nah, there's going to be a
back and forth. You're going to be on Kicker Keep. Ain't no We
going to have, you know what I mean? He was like, "Listen, I
know you got to run your content." I was like, "Fuck yeah, we
got to run our content." But he was like, "Hell yeah, bro. I'm
cool with it as long as I just get to say my piece." I was like,
"Bro, [__] it." So, he'll be on Kicker Keith. We're
going to have a couple of cool [__] too. Y'all better
[__] tune into that. But, bro, this other [__]
I You know what? I'm not going to read. I'm going to read other
I'm not going to read it. I am going to read other [__]
What? I'm not going to read it. I am going to read other [__]
But let me just say this. Let me just say this real quick. Let
me just say this real quick to those of you that are confused.
>> I know a lot of you people had this >> just joined
>> idea that you always say awkward. >> You don't
even sound like you.
that's what it is. >> Oh, is that what it is? just >> I
think so. Yeah, I never used this sound. Um, but I I think I
might have set it up so that when I enter like a a >> like
it says something for By the way, the voice you're hearing is
an old team speak legend. Okay. He was the force soy boy in DG's.
His name was >> Soy boy. I got you. >> The foy boy.
You Okay.
Uh, we're listening to Corantos. What's he talking >> Uh,
I was listening Corantos here. I don't know what else he's got
going on, but I'll just I'll just talk to him about it after.
Okay. >> Oh, Sophia, do you like the heads? We've got like
a unified style now. Well, no. I just messaged I just added him
on uh on Discord and then I said you can come over if you want.
>> Uh so whether he's on stream or off stream, we'll see
what he's doing in a little while. What am I over? I think I
think so. I restarted my laptop. I'm pretty sure that's what
made the difference here, guys. >> Restarted the old laptop.
Now the mic's not [__] up anymore. OBS is okay. Everything's
good. [__] It scared it scared the [__]
out of me. I was trying to keep up with your content. I don't
want to participate on it, but I I don't mind listening. And
at some point, you're like, "Oh, whoever thinks Mantis is winning
right now, they're stupid." So, I immediately message you being
like, "I think Mantis is winning, and I'm and you're stupid."
And a couple seconds after, I hear someone in chat asking, "Is
Wolf Gang saying that she's winning?" And then you immediately
say, "Oh, no. And by the way, I'm not getting any DMs from Wolf
Gang." And I immediately got upset because you're a liar and
a cheating thief. No, I it wasn't Wolf. It wasn't your DMs that
I was referring to. It was somebody who DM'd me before that.
That's all I was saying. So, I wasn't talking about objectively
wrong. Oh, I'm sorry. It doesn't matter when you're wrong. Okay.
Listen, I got to be a little bit cuz Kelly isn't here. So, somebody
>> make up for it. >> All right. >> I can Nobody
can make up for Kelly. Okay. But I'm just saying >> nobody
can replace Kelly. True. That's all I heard there. >> I
don't think they're >> Kelly is irreplaceable.
>> Yeah. True. >> She is irreplaceable. That is true.
Oh yeah. Wow. >> Here's why. Corantos came on to Destiny's
stream. Okay, I'll check this >> Well, you got to share
with the group so I can see. >> I will share in just a
second.
>> this [__] I just read a book all day. It's
both I respect it so much and also I just like can't be. Okay,
I >> I am not going to lie to you. The fact that he's doing
it with the iPad in my opinion for some reason is more entertaining
to watch. like him on his chair looking down and reading. It
feels like ASMR. I don't can't tell you. >> Yeah, I'm I'm
sure it's good. I just like I stopped caring about the Israel
Palestine stuff. What the happened? My presentation tab just
crashed. Oh, >> are we going to judge Corantos based on
how difference how different this is, like what he actually leaked
versus what he what he said. >> He leaked stuff. Well,
he had new clips from Mitch Jones that Mitch Jones didn't include,
which was like basically just >> Well, it was basically
just them yelling at each other in the car and then them actually
driving away and still yelling at each other, >> but not
the fight. The fight wasn't >> Why would it be? The only
part that people want to see. And of course, Corantos would have
it available. Why am I being so mean? It's glad that we got something.
Okay, never mind. >> Yeah. No, it was cool. It was cool.
It was cool. >> I'm going to hit play on this. We're going to
see what Krontos had to say. >> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Is this
the anti-fan Destiny stream? Yeah, the anti-fan Destiny stream
that all of Destiny's closest friends all support. Definitely
the stream that wants to see him him harmed that all of his friends
come on.
>> Yeah. Now, mind you, if being an anti family is you
complain about research streams, I will absolutely fall on that
sword. Okay. I'm just being being fully honest with you. Okay.
>> All right. Brings the book to [__] you.
Not you. Wolf Gang, >> you have any big memes or anything
you want to chat about or
>> I don't want to be here for a long time. I don't want
to be here for a long time. >> Check out, >> why
don't you give uh No, no, actually >> I have spoken to
Mitch Jones. As you know, we will be having him on Monday 6 p.m.
Eastern time. >> He has a lot to say. >> Apparently,
you know, you're there's You know what? I don't want to speak
for the man. I'm going to let him speak for himself. All I'm
going to say is I have been provided a ton of information, way
too much that I can't be saying right now, but I will be saying
it on my stream. Yeah, I'm doing the self plug here, but I'm
I'm I'm low key looking for the host. When are you going to end?
Let me just cut to the chase. When are you going to end? >> Probably
9:00. 2 hours. >> Okay, thank you. Thank you. See, you're
you're read my mind. You know what I >> Yeah, true, sick
boy. We are best >> But what's your thoughts on Mitch Jones?
>> just like you've already asked, what's your opinion
on him? >> Destiny's closest friends like Cherry and Quean.
No, but like go look at the Discord. There's a bunch of people
who are in here who are like close friends of Destiny. They don't
hop on the stream as much, but yeah, they're they're all
>> Here's my issue with
>> this is like a big issue that I have with people. >> I
hate you want to help me out. Don't forget, throw me a couple
subs on kick would be super helpful. Uh you can donate through
Streamlabs. The links are available in the description of the
video on YouTube and on the channel on kick. You could uh it
even helps if you just subscribe on YouTube or follow on kick.
Those are both helpful actions. Uh super chats on YouTube as
well. You could become a member on YouTube. Obviously, I would
rather you did it on kick where I get a higher split, but you
do you. Whatever is the most convenient if you want to help me
out. I love you guys. Thank you. Tom is going live soon. Is Tom
going live soon? I don't think there's I don't think Tom is going
to give us Tom 10 anymore. I think if we want the Tom 10 in itch
scratched, we we're going to have to go somewhere else. Tom Furery
scheduled for 11:15 p.m. Answering questions. Back to
Hey, Uptown Loop, thank you for the sub. The gifted sub, buddy.
That's what I'm talking about. That's a gifted sub. Let's go.
We are We are one gifted into our 25 gifted goal or 25 sub goal.
We are $10 into our $60 stream goal. Jeez, we fell off, guys.
We fell off. That's all that you can say is we fell off. Oh,
Liberal chat.
$10 super chat. You get the you get the notification for that
shortly. You went
for Tom, you're probably going to have to watch Queen Bods. I
think we've seen everything except uh what have we not seen one
of the Tom streams. I think we've seen basically everything for
the Tom 10. Smink's got a tweet tease
>> Wait, how did I get Oh, Teeth Shatter just dumped another
five gifted in in kick. Thank you so much, Teeth Shatter. We
got a Minkx tweet provided to us by Snick. Oh, it's on the TUMAD
stuff. As someone who experienced it firsthand and spoke about
it, I think this tweet is insane. Not even 10 minutes after they
announced his passing. Well, I think it was actually 24 minutes
or so. Oh, 20 bucks from Mike Amazing on YouTube.
>> Thank you. >> He asks, "Does Kick mobile have
DVR yet? I swear that app is so garbage." I don't think Kick
Mobile would have DVR because Kick the web app doesn't have DVR.
Did you like the Destiny and Mark Lamont Hill combo? STV Philly
asks. I thought it was okay. Um I didn't watch all of it. I thought
it was okay. I felt like um Lamont Hill had he was just he was
trying to have a conversation, right? He didn't want to be too
aggressive, but when he went and talked to Hassan, it seemed
like his positions were quite a bit further off than what I would
have expected.
I kind of I kind of knew he's very pro Palestine. So when he
talked to Destiny, they found a lot of common ground. They had
that conversation and it was good. But I really when he went
to Hassan stream, when Mark Lamont Hill went to Hassan stream,
it seemed like he shifted leftward quite a bit or like more pro
Palestinian. So I I'm not saying that's bad. I think it's good
to like just talk with people and not try to be insanely combative.
So I enjoyed it, but I also I don't know quite where he actually
lands. Yeah, like hiding his power level, Dr. Zas. Exactly. But
I I think that's fine for like an initial conversation. He was
more masked off on Hassan stream. Yeah, it's tatted on his forearm.
Is it from the river to the sea on his forearm or is it like
a map of Palestine? Are we excited for the streamer awards? Yeah,
I'm I'm QT Cinderella's biggest fan viewer, guys. For sure. 100%.
Don't you know? Everyone knows.
Dixo knows. Hold on. Let's see. I forgot we missed this piece
of Tom 10. And if I don't have anybody coming in here, I might
just watch it because now I uh I just had some alcohol to talk
to,
you know, because I was really nervous about talking to Krontos.
But now, you know, after an ounce and a half of alcohol, maybe
I'll watch some more content. Okay. Uh, we have enough info to
know Tom hired her at 17 and dated her at 18. So, Tom was on
a stream and he basically said he up and was like, "Yeah, I started
dating this girl." And he almost almost certainly admitted to
to like finding her when she was a minor. And he was like right
as she turned 18, we started dating. And like I think as the
story unfolds, it was basically that he hired her on in like
Pizza Hut or another job and he was like 27 or 28 and he started
dating this like 18-year-old, freshly 18-year-old at his job.
Oof.
Yeah. Can we get the Tom text on that? The Tom text on the uh
the age difference. Aren't you on ADHD meds? I thought alcohol
was a no no. Uh no. I think is alcohol and ADHD meds bad? Raises
blood pressure and heart activity. raises the rate of heart problems.
It's it's an increased risk, but I don't think it's like that
bad. I also I don't drink to excess either. Like I had I feel
like I'm uh I can feel alcohol after having like an ounce of
alcohol. So, as I try to say that so I had like an ounce of alcohol
and I can feel that. So, I I have like no tolerance. It's already
fine. Don't drink very much. Alcohol plus SSRIs are way worse.
Yeah. It raises your tolerance. Well, I'm taking like ADHD meds
and I have for like a decade and yeah, I just don't drink very
much. So, there is so much controversy. Reban Rubin with another
fantastic dad joke. Okay, sorry. We should address the the message
we got on screen here.
>> Risix's in Tom's Discord being a [__] disturber
like he is. We have enough info to know Tom hired her at 17 and
dated her at 18, which is very sus. I didn't hire her at 17.
Lol. What? I didn't even meet her until she was 18. The job she
was hired for, she had to be 18 to work it. I hired her. She
worked for me for a while. She quit and moved to another state
and then we started talking. We didn't have a relationship.
Sorry. We didn't have a relationship outside of the professional
one until she quit. And I didn't know she existed until she had
already turned 18.
Now, that might be true. Nico Sams on Karantos' stream. Kick.com/corantos.
Q o r a n ts kick.com/caratos
about the food about the country. >> Come here. Come here,
bro. Erdogan going to be your ass. >> Was that Turkish?
>> Dude, Erdogan is the president, bro. >> Oh, my
bad. Mo, it just sounded like you know
the prime minister or something. >> I'm kidding. Okay.
Uh,
>> brother cuz I know you're not Turkish. You are a you.
And you know what? There's nothing wrong with that. There's nothing
wrong. Literally, first of all, >> I'm the prime minister,
not the >> I'm not Turkish. I'm Greek. >> Disgusting.
Shout out Turkey. Anyways, um, talk to me. I'm I'm >> What
is this cope? I'm not Turkish. I'm Greek. Those are the same
thing. Let's be real, guys. Donation notification stuck. Oh,
yeah. I see that. Hold on, I'll fix it. >> No, I said on
the stream with Daniel, you said some anti-semitic.
>> What was it? >> I could pull it up, but you dipped
into, you know, like why do all these like, you know, why are
they all in the banks? Like why do they all you know like why
are all in the banks like that's an interesting question you
know I don't know if you so hard >> I mean yeah you did
>> I don't remember and you don't have any goddamn examples
>> uh sometimes the super chats get stuck >> if I
hard enough you would have known just like that one back in the
40s that jQued a little too hard but um >> I just I just
told you you just said I remember the clip you were just like
you were talking about like man it makes you you're like Daniel
like isn't it weird how all theers
though like isn't that I heard there was Tom said that. I feel
>> there was Tom 10, but we kind of watched all the Tom
10. >> I can pull it up. >> Which by the way is very
>> I don't know. There's there's maybe one other clip of
Tom 10. Okay, we can watch the time stamp. Oh, someone's already
got someone's already got the clip sent to me in DMs. Jesus,
>> you guys are ruthless with Tom. Okay, >> I'm right.
>> You guys are absolutely [__] ruthless on
Tom. >> Wait, can you share screen? >> Yeah. Yeah,
I'm going to share screen. That was also I just left the Discord
recently. So, get that screen share going. Okay. Tom clip. >> Oh,
that's K. >> That's K. That is K. It says K right there.
So, this clip is 3 years old. Let's just listen. I'm sure nothing
weird is said. Okay. I'm sure there's nothing weird being said
here. It's all probably above board. What do you think of Destiny
saying he likes that you bring people like Cherry on? He said
he didn't say why he liked it. I have some suspicions on why
he likes it, but I'll keep them to myself because he said he
didn't want to talk about it. Okay. >> I was 20. >> I
think I like this stream. And basically, other than one specific
example, it's like if I was friends with somebody, I'm not going
to not have them on stream just cuz Destiny doesn't like them.
And but at the same time, I also wouldn't just sit here. If Cherry
wanted to come on and just talk Destiny 247, which she doesn't.
She's never done that. She doesn't want to do that as far as
I know. But if she did want to do that, I probably just wouldn't.
Like, we just wouldn't get along, so it it doesn't really matter.
>> I don't have a hate, but for him, you're >> Yeah.
Yeah. Uh, so let's let's watch Tom. See what Tom has to say.
>> I I didn't know that or I was 29, about to turn 29.
I didn't know that she had just turned 18. I just assumed she
was older than that for the longest time. Um, she worked for
me for a while. Eventually,
she moved away. When she moved away, we started talking. And
then after we were already like kind of in the midst of everything,
I find out she's 18, just turned 18. Um, and >> after we're
kind of in the midst of everything, I learned she's 18, just
turned 18. And then what does he say over in the DMs?
We have the DMs here. I didn't hire her at 17. I didn't even
meet her until she was 18. That's not true cuz it seems like
once you guys were in a relationship, she just turned 18. Oh,
you can't hear the video. Oh, that's weird. Give me a sec. I'll
fix >> You're fine. >> That's weird. >> I heard
it, but I'll listen again. >> That's really weird that
it wasn't showing, but I'll I'll fix it, guys. >> You having
audio problems is weird. >> No, I don't have audio problems.
I don't The audio was fine all night. I don't know why that happened
suddenly. I don't know why that happened. >> It's me. I'm
doing it. >> That's weird. Okay, well, watch again.
>> I think. I didn't hear her. I was 29, about to turn
29. I didn't know that she had just >> Oh, is this quiet?
Hold on. I'll turn it up. We'll go back a little bit more. Maybe
with more con Maybe with more tom text it'll make sense. Okay,
>> we just need a little more tom text. >> It's not
illegal. It >> Jesus. That is way louder than I expected
to be. Holy [__] >> A lot of tom text. >> Yeah,
we're missing the tom text. The tom text,
as Mantis would say. >> It's still disgusting and creepy.
That's
>> You know, my last girlfriend's like 11 years younger
than me.
>> I was 28. I I didn't know that or I was 29 about to
turn 29. I didn't know that she had just turned 18. I just assumed
she was older than that for the longest time. Um, she worked
for me for a while. Eventually, she moved away. When she moved
away, we started talking. And then after we were already like
kind of in the midst of everything, I find out she's 18, just
turned 18. And
I I almost like broke things off right then because I said I
was like, I'm going to be looked at as a freaking creepier. Like
I'm going to This is obviously going to be looked at as predatory
behavior. I I'm older, more mature. Um and I'm not going to like
I'm not going to lie and say she was super mature. She wasn't.
Uh I'm not. >> Let's just pause right there. Okay. I feel
like that's >> this is money not to lie. >> That's
all the tom text we need. Jesus. Anyway, so that's the Tom text
you need for this DM or this Discord
>> That's all we need. >> I think that's all we need.
Raven Ruben, you're having a bad effect on me. Okay. Pizza place.
What is it? Domino's. It was actually Pizza Hut, but Domino's
is based. Could not torture that info out of me. Yeah. I mean,
I feel like th this happened to people. I'm I swear to God, this
was during the pandemic. People got like isolated in a way they'd
never been isolated before and they just started admitting to
really weird [__] Like every thought they had in
their head, they're just like, "Yeah, I think that. Why not?
I do think that." Thinking that is based. Vos Vos talking about
all his lolly [__] He just thinks that's based. Okay.
I think it was the pandemic. I think it was all the isolation.
People just started admitting to weird [__] >> Why?
Well, I think it was, like I said, it's the isolation. She was
18. No. What did I miss? Base perpetually cancelled. She was
18. What did I miss? Nothing. There's nothing weird there. That
was a totally normal and healthy clip. Let's go. Let's go. I'm
pretty sure Perpetually canceled is actually Tom. Like, if I
had to guess, I'm pretty sure it's actually Tom. >> Oh,
that's your YouTube chat. >> Yeah, it's my YouTube chat.
>> Well, we could just ask Tom. Is that >> He talks
too much while Tom is streaming. Maybe. Did you see this Kanye
vid? Is it the advertisement? I saw the
>> Oh, no. I I saw this vid, too.
>> What' you say? >> Your thoughts on the Palestinians?
>> I I don't have enough information on that. I'm straight.
I'm straight up [__] from south side of Chicago born
in Atlanta. I don't have that. I don't have enough information.
It's love for everybody, but don't pull me into that conversation.
I got people I got 14 kids dying every week in my city. You know
what I'm saying? So, talk to me about >> All right. Thank
you. >> Hey, appreciate you, man. Thank you,
>> Kanye started to identify bait questions. He knows.
Okay, >> he's becoming aware. >> JTLK is trying to
pretend an 18-year-old was groomed. Well, I mean, technically,
if he met her when she was under 18, it's just weird. It's just
another weird thing. Okay, there's no laws being broken here.
There's no laws being broken. Tom shouldn't go to jail.
It's fine. Okay, it's fine.
>> Tom's live. Congrats, guys. Tom's live. Ah, doesn't
groomed imply intent or is that wrong? I mean, I have no idea,
honestly. I'm just like, it's just like a funny clip. It's really
not that. It's just like It's just another funny clip. I'm sorry.
Was a 17-year-old a baddy, though? That is the question really.
>> It's your question, not mine. >> What's that?
Sorry. >> I said that would be a question you would want
to ask, not me. >> honestly, I think when you're that young,
you should never date someone that much older than you. I don't
I'm not going to call it grooming. I think other stuff has to
be involved for grooming, but I don't know. >> I think
like once you're once you're 30, you should probably wait until
girls cancel or graduate college to date them. Like that's probably
just going to be the good norm most of the time. Okay. I think
that's like probably Wait, so it was just Tom bad but based when
Destiny's 35 plowing 19year-olds? No, I make fun of Destiny a
lot. I don't know if you realize this. I've been banned from
DG chat a lot for specifically pointing that out. perpetually
canceled. No, I've I've pointed that out a lot, actually. I had
some fantastic jokes, by the way. They were I've never laughed
harder than joking about that sometimes. Okay, it's like the
hardest I've ever laughed on the internet. Just tickle. Do you
care at all about the Fantana review of Kanye's album? It was
all over Twitter. Like the one where he just says he's not going
to review it. I thought that was the punch line. I'm not actually
going to review the album.
>> Raven Rubin with the $5 super chat. If he gets into
legal trouble, do you think he'll have to do Tom unity service?
Tom
service. That's fantastic. Reuben Ruben, thank you very much
for the super chat. Thank you very much for the super chat. You
just can't hear the truth. I mean, it's not it's like fine. It's
like whatever. I'm a father of five and even this is me. Yeah,
Ruben. Reuben just dumps like $10 to $15 into chat every night
to make his dad jokes and I love it. I'm here for it, Reuben.
Thank you, >> SCB. Why are you asking that from the chat?
Don't you have perms to get in the >> It's not even like
bad necessarily. Like I actually don't even think it's bad. He
doesn't have perms, by the way. I I'm trying to be really judicious
with who I give perms to. Not that like STD couldn't have them.
I just >> trying to give you >> go to the waiting
room. >> He could. >> That's mostly what I mean.
>> Yeah. I don't think it's a It's not a thing. It's not
like, oh, older men can't date younger women. I don't think older
women should do it to younger men either. that age gap. It's
like
>> you're looking for something a bit
>> about the person. So, generally speaking, I think your
standard for maturity, if you start dating someone that much
older than you, I think it like lowers. You get like an unrealistic
idea of like how mature someone should be when they grow up because
you're dating someone older than you and they're like on the
same maturity level as you. I just think if you're if you're
like 30 plus and you're dating like 20 like n I don't know 18
to 21 year olds if you're dating them I think it just probably
says something about you not being able to find women who are
older
right it's like it like you probably have some issues that are
going on >> I would say it's like a rule it's not like
guaranteed like for Destiny >> although I don't think he
goes younger than 21 or anything not that it matters. But like
for Destiny, it's like he just wants uh physical relationships,
right? He just wants So, I don't know. He's just optimizing for
that. Whoever's willing to go. I guess >> I'm more so thinking
about like I think the the biggest example I can remember is
in high school there would usually be college
like guys that would date girls in high school. And you wouldn't
realize it until you got into college yourself that oh my god,
I was dating the most immature dude in college. Like there's
a reason why he was dating me in high school and not someone
else in college. But like you never realize this until you grow
up. So >> Oh, STV Phillies in the waiting room. >> Get
that through to people. Do >> Yeah, he's dragged in. Here
he is. STV Philly. How's it going? >> I'm good. I was just
listening to what Jerry was saying.
And then I didn't get to hear the end of that. Cherry, could
you just back up for like 10 seconds and repeat like the last
10 seconds of what you were just saying? >> I was saying
that you tend to not realize it when you're like a high school
girl dating a college guy until you get into college and realize,
"Oh my god, I was dating the most immature guy in college." You
You don't really understand the level of maturity that most people
are at in that age because that guy is dating below his age.
>> Yeah. And women I think my perception is that women
tend to mature faster than men. Do you agree with that? >> Uh
I have no idea really. >> Me neither. It's just um it's
just like my perception of things. It seems like um a lot of
times like around the ages of 16, 17, 18 uh women are more um
focused on their studies and uh a lot of the kid uh guys around
that age are you know looking for the next party and stuff. Um
at least this is when I was 17 like 20 years ago. Um I'm older
than
So um but no um when Vash when Vash got into this whole trouble
uh and Ethan was going over his stuff um e uh Vos Ethan kept
playing clips of Vos, right? And I would always
every time the question what whatever the question came up like
whatever Das was trying to explain in his debates, Ethan would
would would say like, "No, bro. Nobody's wondering that. Nobody's
like thinking that you're a weirdo for even having these debates
and convos." And Vash would then get to the question of um you
know, there are situations where a minor could date an adult
and it can turn out to be good, right? And every time people
hear that, they automatically think of a man, an older man dating
a younger woman most of the times. Um, and so me personally,
I had an experience where
um, I was out with a bunch of friends and we uh were just walking
around our neighborhood. We weren't old enough to get into the
bars or anything, but uh, it was a little bit late. I was about
14. Uh, all my friends are around the exact same age. Uh, so
I was about 14. Maybe it was like 9 10:00. Um, and we saw these
two drunk women, and I always try to think about their age, but
they had to have been between 25 and 30, just just remembering
how they looked and like what they were talking about. And they
had their own apartment at this like very expensive, uh, apartment
complex where I lived. And long story short, um, they were drunk,
like I said, leaving walking home from the bar. And we kind of
followed them. You know, we're kids. We're like 14, 15, and there's
these girls talking to us. and and not girls, there were women
talking to us and showing us attention. So, we were just dumb
boys, dumb kids. And so, we walked with them and we followed
them. And then one thing I I don't remember all the details,
but just to make the story not drag out, uh it ended up like
one of my friends like ended up like eating one of these girls
out like and and
for him, right? like that he that would probably I would imagine
for him that was a cool memory, right? I don't think he was,
you know, damaged by that, right? Like I don't think he was um
I don't think he's going through life thinking about that every
day and feeling damaged, right? Was it good for him? I don't
I wouldn't say it was like a net positive for his life like uh
it could have affected him negatively, but >> what's happening?
Um they Ethan H3H3 was making it out to be like or Ela it seemed
like more was like this could never happen. Show me when this
happens. Show me like how this could ever be a positive thing.
And I don't know. I've been rambling for a minute. What do you
guys think?
>> Uh I Hold on. Is that coming through? Yeah, it is coming
through. I don't know. That was like was I I think that's weird.
I think that's really weird. Especially you said are were all
your friends 14. That's like really young, dude. That's actually
really weird. No, no doubt. No doubt about it. The more I think
about that situation like the I don't like I feel like the women
So
>> it didn't explained positive
like what the positive outcome is there. But it sounds like you're
using that story to be an example of a case where it's a positive
outcome. >> Like a child and a Yeah. where like a child
and adult have a positive relationship. So you said it's not
negative. Is it Is it positive? >> No. So So I don't like
truly know how this kid felt about it. Like uh I don't Yeah,
I haven't talked to him in a while. So I don't truly know exact
like we haven't talked about his feelings on did he feel like
he got raped that night or like what what like we we've never
talked about that. However, I remember thinking about it that
night and everybody thinking it was the coolest thing in the
world, right? Um,
I don't know. I don't know if those women remember that night
and how they would look at it, right? But I I I don't think it
had on him uh the normal negative effects you would think that
interaction would have. And I say all of that to say that
um these debates don't need to be had. This is not like a um
something I'm put putting forth as like a talking point or or
or like a point against or or point towards what Vosch was saying.
All I'm saying is like
I want to know other people's opinion about that, right? Like
like do so logistical you're saying you think it's like bad all
around, right? And I tend to agree with you pro. >> So
it's like it's literally what Vosch said. It's like as the rule
it'll probably be really bad as like an act. It's entirely possible.
It's fine. But just as a rule, possibly 99.9999999%
of the time it's bad. So, as a rule, it shouldn't happen. It
should be possibly even like illegal, right? In that case, I
think that should 100% be illegal. >> [__]
absolutely. >> It's like 30year-old women or however old
these women were. I don't know if they're 30, but like, you know,
majority age women, 14y olds should always be illegal. Okay.
I I don't think >> Sorry, somebody said child in 14 is
different. I No, don't make that argument. Okay. >> Found
the Bosch. >> Yeah, you should go. >> So So So here,
>> back to BG with you. >> What I'm thinking is like
none of us felt scarred by that night. I don't think he did either.
Right. So like >> you can't know that. >> I can't.
You're right. And I don't >> guys will never share to their
other guys like, "Oh yeah, I felt so
>> Yeah. I you would mock the [__] out of some
dude if if this dude had sex with like a 25 or 30-year-old woman
and he was like, "Oh, I feel so weird." Everybody be like, "You're
gay. You're so gay. >> You love you love." So, I'm just
saying that absolutely would have happened to that guy if he
said he didn't enjoy that >> Yeah. Cuz like I said, like
at the time we're all looking at it like, you know, like it was
just a cool crazy night that we're all going to remember for
the rest of our lives. And as I >> Wait, why are the rest
of you going to remember it? For the rest of you, like
Highline, line of sight, could you would you watch this? >> We
all watched it. Yes. Yes, we all watched it. And her and her
friend watched it, too. >> Um and I know that they know
that it was weird because like they >> Wait, you guys watched
him do this? >> Yeah. Yes.
>> I'm now traumatized
to this. What the That's >> He's not okay. Go peck on your
friend. >> Yeah, it is odd. And it's something that happened
and I don't think people talk about it enough to like on an on
a level where you um actually break down like how you know cuz
men guys always talk about like oh I like it would be so cool
to bang my teacher or bang this or such and such and so hot this
older woman right and you're like 14 15 you think like oh it'd
be such a fantasy to them right but when it comes down to it
like this it really is up and I don't think men talk about um
like how like what it is really that they're experiencing in
that moment cuz you know for me I I I don't hold any traumatization
towards that incident. Like I said when I've never had it like
complete conversation with him about how he feels now, right?
So, it's just something I thought like, you know, if this has
ever happened to anybody else, like if you're like an underage
dude who's banged uh heads with a chick who's, you know, plus
10 years your age at the very least. Um, you know, talk about
I don't know like what the dynamics of that are and why it's
not like the coolest thing in the world, >> All right.
Yeah. I don't know >> because like I said, the way I remember
it, the way we talked about it was it >> it was positive.
You had thought of it positive. is weird. It was a very weird
thing to happen. I I don't agree with you at all. >> If
I'm psychoanalyzing,
most most people are raised to sort of view older people as like
an authority. So, when you have early experiences with older
people, that can really um damage your sense of boundary and
uh sense of self in a way. like being able to establish boundaries
and being able to articulate what you want to do and your feelings
it yeah it will erode that >> if I remember if I reme if
I am remembering this situation correctly
um it was sort of like like we were so excited to be interacting
with these women right and they were sort of like playing with
the idea of oh look at these like cute 14year-old 15year-old
boys and they were drunk on top of that right and there was nobody
there to like
to to put the brakes on anything like we were all looking at
it positive to positively. She was looking at it positively.
Um and now that I'm an adult, yeah, I think back at how [__]
up that was. Um but so you guys are are are saying the things
that I I'm thinking, but a lot of times I tell that story, people
are like that's awesome. That's cool. Like they a lot of people
don't see a lot of things wrong like there. I'm just talking
about my real life. I this is the first this might be the first
time I've told this story on the internet but like yeah like
whatever yeah my group of friends or anybody talks about this
story it's always yeah it's just always looked at as just some
crazy that happened that night like one of our friends got raped
right you know I don't know um okay I just wanted to just get
your thoughts on it I guess there's not not not too much else
to expand on there >> all right yeah I mean we'll probably
use that example going forward I don't know it's I mean it's
kind of interesting I feel like I am having having a hard time
engaging with it. Okay. I don't It's >> Yeah. No, it's
it's it's weird. It's crazy, but it is something that happened,
right? Yeah. >> Yeah. How old were these women, do you
think? Did you Did you know? >> I think I didn't know for
sure, but like I said, they had just left the bar, so they were
at the very least 21, but our
uh you know, our our guess was that they were about 25 26.
>> Like, that was our our guess. I don't even think we
ever even asked them. Um, but just the way they were acting and
the way they, like I said, the the one girl had like a a nice
car and they lived in this expensive, which doesn't really mean
much, but it just I don't know. It made us think they were a
little bit older, but Yeah. >> Yeah. Yeah. Okay. All right.
>> That's all I was trying to say in in chat. I don't know
why I said 17 where we were actually 14. Um, but I I thought
17 would be a little bit better to engage with, a little bit
easier to engage with, I guess. Yeah. >> Yeah. The 14 that
is that put the whammy on me for sure. I was not expecting.
>> It's a crazy story. >> Jay Stock is an incel so
he has no idea what he just listened to. >> I guess so.
>> That's the thing. Like it wasn't so outlandish outlandish
to us. Like it was crazy that the fact that you know it was these
older women but like we were hooking up all the time at that
age. Like it wasn't >> the the hooking up part like the
having at 14 15 you weren't hooking. When I say hooking up I
mean kissing
late bloomer. I was in marching band. Okay. I wasn't hooking
up with anyone at that age.
>> uh 14 was 15 was like where it started in my school.
So, >> yeah, other people. >> I lost my virginity
at uh 14, I believe, or maybe it was 15, but yeah, it was right
around that age. Um but yeah. All right. Uh that that's all I
got, guys. >> Yeah, cool. Thanks for coming on. >> All right.
All right. Peace. >> Yeah. See you. >> So, anyway,
I'm looking for who we're going to write out to on kick. Gonna
let that hang there for a second. Probably not, actually. I don't
know if I'm gonna I'm getting food right away and I don't know
if I'm going to keep streaming and eat. How long have we been
streaming for? Only five hours. Um I don't have groceries tonight.
So I've not been ordering food. I've been cooking recently, but
now I ordered pizza cuz it was cheap. Cheap cheap cheap. >> Did
you get >> I did not get kick.comtomoolery.
Dude, there's not going to be it's not going to be interesting.
It's just going to be sleep strength.
Like there's an idea that I was abusive to Sassifress.
>> Um obviously I'm not going to think that I was abusive
no matter what. So I'm going to feel >> all right >> maybe
we get some top 10 >> but I think that I question myself
on this sort of enough and with sassifrass again people want
to make it about Mantis leaving and Zia from what I understand
clarified that it was not over Mantis leaving. Mantis was like
the straw that broke the camel's back. But Sass and I, we used
to have phone calls where we would watch movies or TV shows.
And this was like on and off for
um for a while. Like we would watch every night for a while and
then stop talking for a while and then watch for a while and
then stop talking for a while. And when I say stop talking, we
didn't just stop talking overall. We would just like we weren't
on calls as much anymore. And >> oh, am I not showing the
screen? Sorry, guys. I think we had probably not been watching
movies or TV shows consistently for about a year.
And >> wait, what kind of pizza did you order? >> Barbecue
chicken. >> And she was always saying like, "Hey, >> I
feel like chicken >> maybe." Uh, >> yeah, barbecue
chicken's good pizza now.
>> that you've like replaced me. >> It's good pizza
archetype. I didn't replace you or I just I don't like getting
off stream and then getting into a call and
>> lots of times I would just want to show and that's it
and she would want to debate stuff and I didn't want to >> uh
I'm just going to switch headphones really quickly. Give me >> want
a relationship but you told her you don't eat date. >> This
guy is Mantis's ex by the way. Hold on a second. I'm switching
headphones. >> Oh that's Mantis's ex. That's a weird What's
her ex doing donating to talk to >> It's probably loud.
That's the case that she never told me that she wanted a relationship.
>> at any point? No. >> What do you >> We didn't
We weren't flirty. >> We didn't have like romantic text
messages. We didn't have where were like Yeah. We just don't
have those. Um that wasn't part of our relationship. >> Maybe
it's a weird >> like has been a mod for this channel for
a really long time and is really invested in the outcome. Uh
um >> Tony had pizza from like a pizza chain that had a
super cheap deal on >> and then also was a producer on
the documentary as well. And there are times where we would talk
about the fact that like yes, once this actually makes enough
money like hopefully you'll get paid as well. And so yes, there's
just an investment outside of just being friends with me. I I'm
sure that that was like why it started and why that was a huge
motivator. But she she like helped build the Discord. She owned
the Discord. Um she helped build so many parts of this channel.
She was the one who was coming up with all the content. Um she
would help with like branding and all that. She has like a stake
in this channel and had invested. >> I mean I don't know.
I literally I don't know. Yeah. >> It just seems like that's
um
>> I don't know. I'll never understand.
diving out so much of like your own stream to other people. Too
much of a control freak, I think. >> Oh, not me. But you
know what? I'm I'm good at delegating stuff. Okay. So, but I
trying to think. I don't like letting people take on a whole
bunch for free. Like I I don't know. Like Wolf Gang's done art
and I think I've mostly paid him for the art and I've like I've
had an editor and it's like I it feels for weird for free that
it's like kind of weird to do
so much time and effort in this channel that it wasn't just our
relationship that
um that kept her here. There was there was a lot more than that.
But yeah, because I said yes, I lied to her about the relationship
with Mantis. Um, and I the thing is is that there is another
girl that I've spoken to that I did tell Sass about well after
where I said yes I was talking to this girl for a while. Um,
there were >> there's another there was a reason for me
telling her when I did but >> I wonder if what if this
is why Sass was so much like I told you that this would happen
if you keep chatters. Was it another chatter? She was well aware
that there were sometimes girls that I talked to. I I don't know
about the >> What other woman has offended him?
>> uh Stardust. >> I'm just I'm just kidding. I'm
just kidding. Not making accusations, >> but there are
girls that I would talk to and be flirty with for like a week
or two and then that's it. Um and that was Yeah. And that that
again there were two including Manthus. one, two that ever sent
me any nudes and one that I would talk to here and there in calls
once in a while and uh but never sent me any pictures. Never
like we never had like a like or anything like that. Um and that's
in the course of three to four years of doing this. So >> mine
wave spitten. Where's mine waves?
>> Tom, you need >> Oh, right here. need to realize
that
>> nobody is that invested in your content without getting
paid doing it without other motives. >> I'm not
mind waves is kind of spitting right there >> that like
our friendship was a huge part of it. >> I didn't realize
it wasn't at all. Speed it up. >> Um I I think she was
doing it because she was a good friend, but we had >> I
don't know. >> These sorts of things and the dynamics of
our relationship to where if those all just went unsaid for so
long, then I I could understand how people would come to these
conclusions. I I think that when we have those conversations
about uh about the fact that yeah, like I'm not I'm not going
to get invested with somebody online. I'm not going to have like
a a girlfriend that's on the internet and especially probably
not one that that like I work with or that's a a mod for me or
any of those things. Like yeah, I think that I think that I was
uh I think that we were both clear on our relationship and if
SAS felt different as she never she never told me about this.
Um, so yeah, we we were talking on and off for a while and then
over the last year, we we hadn't been talking because
I did I quit my job to where I was getting off at like 3:00 a.m.
and I was just barely streaming around that point. So every time
I got off around 2:00 or 3, then I was just calling her. We would
talk for a while and then watch a show and I would fall asleep.
Um, but then once I left that job, I got another job where I
was just working in the mornings and I had to go to bed earlier
and I was streaming consistently now. So now I'm streaming, getting
off, going straight to bed and then getting up in the morning.
So I told her consistently, if you want to talk, you have to
you have to we would have to do it before I get on stream. and
she says, "Well, the only times that I can do that is on the
weekends." And I'd say, "Okay, so then call me on the weekends."
She'd say, "Well, I want my personal time on the weekends." And
I say, "Okay, well then if there's a day you don't want your
personal time, let me know." Um, around the time that we stopped
talking, I was also I was frustrated that one I would get off
and I wanted to go to sleep, but she wanted to debate and argue
with me and it was just like hyper sensitivity or yeah, I wanted
to go to bed and I wanted to like slow down and rest and uh yeah,
she wanted to fight with me on and I just wasn't feeling it.
Um, there was that, there was that like watching movies and TV
shows and just ended up keeping and I wanted to get to sleep
as fast as possible. This is like personal, not really entertaining
in any way. >> No, I'm just baffled that there are Is it
multiple women? I'm just >> I think it's just a clout thing.
Okay. I think it's just a clout thing. >> What clout? Am
I delusional? >> I think there's like a certain amount
of clout in having like a 100 viewers consistently. I don't know.
I think so. Seems to be the case.
>> I think I just don't know what clout means. I'm >> all
right. I don't know. >> Also, what that is really mean.
What is >> person? Whichever one of you teeth teeth or
whatever calling mind waves
um
an idiot just he says stupid things sometimes but not all the
time. So >> not all the time nicer. Yeah, it's not all
the time. >> Yeah, I don't know. I'm just I'm kind of just
chilling now, guys. I think I'm going to end stream pretty soon.
Unless someone was going to hop on. I am ready to have some food.
Go to sleep. Yeah, I don't know if we have anyone looking to
hop on right now, which is fine. I don't know if Wolf Gang was
planning to stream tonight. Wolf Gan, any Wolf Gangs? He told
me he was going to stream tonight. Is he streaming? He literally
said tomorrow I will be streaming and then he did not stream.
He's in bed. He's definitely not in bed. You ever watch any TwoMad
streams before? No, I haven't really was not super familiar with
uh with Tumad. If not, it's TomTent raid. No, I'm not going to
raid Tom. Does Wolf Gand even sleep? I mean, not early in the
day. Let me see here. Looks like Tree of Logic's talking about
Vouch right now. On Vouch, you guys want to host Star? I'm good.
I'm good. Leafy Bell, I'm sorry. I'm good. I was just going to
host on uh Wait, hold on. Tree might be live on YouTube. Oh,
no. Tree is not live on YouTube. She's copyright struck or something.
Call her. No, I'm good. She's doing content right now. She's
not going to call in. You got any last things you want to get
out, Cherry, before we end? >> No. I hope you guys all
had a decent holiday. I don't know. Valentine's Day is not real.
>> Valentine's Day? I forgot it was Valentine's Day. It
was Valentine's Day >> Oh, you forgot. >> Yeah. I
mean, I I had the same amount of viewers I always do, so wasn't
really a thing. All right, guys. Well, I'm probably going to
end it here and send you guys over to Tree of Logic. Kid, people
are doing riot. Why is there a riot? I think it's good. I think
we're good. You watch a Too Mad come up video, guys. It's It's
like late. Okay, it's pretty late. We good. We Gucci.
We will be streaming more, not tomorrow night, but Friday night.
I'll probably be streaming the full eight hours and we'll see
what's up. I think I'll also almost certainly have my computer
ready tomorrow. I don't know if it's bedtime, but I'm I'm going
to get my food and then start heading to sleep. >> I think
I'm either
Yeah, it's Friday. I think I'm driving to Georgia, so I'll be
gone for like a >> Okay, cool. I don't know. I should I
message Josiah and try to set up a time with him, or do you want
to be here for >> Um, no. I'll still uh set up a time.
>> Yeah. I just >> If anything, I can call in. >> Yeah.
Yeah. >> Like while I'm on the road. >> Sure. I just
Yeah. I mean, I can wait to talk to him, too, if you wanted to
be here for that call. >> Oh, no. No. I don't need to be
there. I just like the content. >> All right. >> I
want to see them all talk again, but I didn't want to bother
uh Adam friend. >> Yeah. Maybe he'll get sent a clip. Maybe
I'll uh try to defend conservatives. Yeah. Thanks for coming
on tonight, guys. It was a good stream. gonna host stream of
logic and then end it. End it
for tonight. Yeah. W stream. Okay. Love you guys. Talk to you
all tomorrow. I think I'll be back. Have a good night.